[Musique]
l'amérique frappée au coeur le monde
occidental déstabiliser c'est une
opération d'une ampleur inouïe qui a
touché les états unis deux avions
détournés par des kamikazes ont détruit
les tours géant du world trade center à
new york les bâtiments se sont effondrés
un peu plus tard un troisième avion
suicide s'est écrasé sur le pentagone
siège des armées américaines la maison
blanche et tous les bâtiments publics
ont été évacués aéroports et frontières
fermées les états unis sont ce soir
coupé du monde partout ailleurs les
bourses s'effondrent
en france le plan vigipirate est
réactivée à bruxelles les locaux de
l'otan évacués pas de revendication a
montré du doigt les talibans condamnent
la violence mais c'est vers oussama ben
laden que se tournent tous les regards
c'est une édition spéciale que nous
consacrons à cette information les faits
les témoignages les premières listes
avec toutes les images et nos invités
dont alain richard ministre de la
défense
bonsoir à tous et merci de votre
attention
incroyable inimaginable
hallucinant les mots font défaut pour
qualifier la très vaste la très
spectaculaire opération terroriste mené
aujourd'hui on va d'abord revivre les
événements le pentagone bien sûr et
surtout ses tours immenses du world
trade center percutées de plein fouet
par deux avions de ligne détournés on a
cru d'abord un accident la panique et
l'incrédulité images commentées par
thierry curtet
l'image est effroyable un premier avion
a déjà percuté la première tour un
deuxième appareil sûr présentes il vise
il percute l'autre tours jumelles du
world trade center il est 9h 14 à new
york le borgne n'a pas dévié sa
trajectoire d'un seul maître transformer
en kamikaze il se crashe sur le symbole
de la toute puissance économique
américaine les prestigieuses twin towers
de new york
quarante minutes plus tard à washington
un troisième avion s'écrase sur le
pentagone
le plus stratégique de tous les
bâtiments militaires américains puis un
quatrième appareil à 747 s'écrase en
pennsylvanie
ces quatre avions de ligne détournés
provenaient de trois villes différentes
et transportait 2 166 passagers
à new york les deux avions transformé en
missile ont percuté les deux tours au
moment de l'arrivée au bureau des 50000
personnes qui travaillait au world trade
center
des dizaines d'employés font des signes
désespérés
d'autres vont choisir de se jeter par
les fenêtres
les deux bâtiments jumeaux mesure plus
de 400 mètres de haut
mais les deux tours véritable monument
de new york ne vont pas résisté bien
longtemps la première se brise par le
milieu bascule et s'effondre
la seconde quelques minutes plus tard
implose et s'écroule
chacun des deux bâtiments peser plus de
300 mille tonnes située au bord d'une
rivière d'un côté mais à dossier au
quartier des affaires de wall street de
l'autre le maire de new york parle d'un
effroyable bilan sans avancer le moindre
chiffre
l'aef à l'aviation civile américaine
décide de fermer tous les aéroports des
états unis plus d'un avion civil est
autorisé à voler les trains doivent
rester en gare les frontières avec le
canada et le mexique sont bouclés les
marchés financiers en chute libre fermé
l'amérique est paralysé à new york
n'avait évidemment jamais connu une
telle apocalypse dans la panique le
maire a même vidé le sud de la ville de
ses habitants vous l'avez entendu il
parle d'un nombre de victimes je cite
terrifiant témoignages rassemblés par
patrick fandio
[Applaudissements]
l'impensable vient de se produire
et c'est la panique au coeur de
manhattan
alors non dans les rues près des deux
tours du world trade center chacun
cherche un abri
les policiers pour ceux qui le peuvent
[Musique]
à 7 heures ce sont des milliers
d'américains qui se rendent au travail
ou dans les centres commerciaux tout
près ce matin ils vivent le drame en
direct
l'effondrement des deux tours de verre
le long de l'hudson river
cette femme raconte qu'elle a entendu un
gros boum
après y'a une grosse fumée tout le monde
a essayé de sortir et on a vu arriver un
autre avion de l'autre côté il y avait
de la fumée partout et des gens qui ont
tenté de sortir par les fenêtres
dans les immeubles entre les débris ce
qu'ils ont pu trouver la porte de sortie
raconte l'incroyable
nous avons entendu une grosse explosion
tout est soudain devenu très sombre il y
avait des débris de verre qui tombait de
partout les gens étaient blessés c'était
une grosse explosion tout était noir il
y avait un nuage de cendres comme de la
neige mais vous le voyez ce n'est pas de
la neige c'est l'immeuble c'était un
cauchemar terrible
après le crash du premier avion il y en
a eu un second ce ils venaient du sud et
a heurté la tour sud vers le haut de
l'immeuble ça ne peut être qu'une action
terroriste c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire
il ya eu une grosse explosion des gens
sont sortis à moitié dénudée et j'ai
tout fait pour essayer de les aider
c'est tout le sud de manhattan qui a été
évacué puis bouclé par des centaines de
policiers et de secouriste alors qu'un
nuage de cendres à son bric c'est
toujours la vitrine financières du monde
l'image saisissante les conditions de
travail des secours était
particulièrement difficile on va faire
le point précisément maintenant sur les
secours dans la ville loïc de la mornais
dans ces deux tours cinquante mille
personnes travaillent chaque jour à 9h
du matin les bureaux sont ouverts
on ignore combien d'hommes et de femmes
se trouvent dans ses murs au moment où
ces images terribles sont tournés
le bilan est assurément dramatique
inchiffrable pour l'instant
il ya d'abord ces centaines de passagers
à bord des avions détournés aussi bien à
new york qu'à washington et pittsburgh
il y à tous ceux qui ont sauté des
étages en flammes pour échapper à la
catastrophe enfin et c'est
malheureusement là que le bilan risque
d'être le plus lourd tous ceux au sol
dans les rues dévastées de manhattan ou
ensevelies sous des étages de gravats
et quelques miraculés
je ne sais pas ça explose et tout s'est
écroulé je suis vivant j'espère aussi
que ma femme est vivant on était 80 2
dans mon bureau
malgré le chaos les secours ont bouclé
toute l'île de manhattan la garde
nationale a été appelée pour épauler
secouristes pompiers et forces de
l'ordre les blessés sont pris en charge
au hasard de leurs rencontres avec les
secours
je me suis retrouvé coincé dans les
escaliers avec un autre type j'étais
blessé à l'épaule et au bras et ensuite
on a couru on a couru
les hôpitaux et la croix-rouge
improvisent des dispensaires de fortune
et de nombreux points pour les dons de
sang le maire de new york a demandé à
tous les habitants de fuir vers le nord
de manhattan pour échapper au nuage de
poussière dans un instant de témoignages
en direct et nos envoyés spéciaux
également à washington et à new york
d'abord on va dire un mot de ses cibles
de toute évidence elles ont été choisis
avec minutie le world trade center c'est
le symbole de la puissance commerciale
et financière américaine le pentagone
c'est bien sûr le saint des saints le
siège de l'armée la plus puissante du
monde jérôme baugnies la splendeur
américaine frapper là où ça lui fait le
plus mal dans sa puissance financière
d'abord dont les tours jumelles du world
trade center était le symbole de tour
construite en 1973 d'une hauteur de 400
m qui dépasse celle du veillât pas state
building
c'est tour du centre mondial du commerce
appartenait aux autorités portuaires des
états de new york et du new jersey elle
hébergeait 500 compagnies
internationales cinquante mille employés
c'était aussi un haut lieu du tourisme
qui attirait chaque mois deux cent mille
visiteurs
aujourd'hui l'un des fleurons de new
york est parti en fumée
autre cible le pentagone le centre de
commandement de la première puissance
militaire mondiale plus de vingt mille
personnes y travaillent c'est ici qu'est
contrôler une puissance de feu comme le
monde n'en a jamais connu 5700 charges
nucléaires sans compter des liens
étroits avec les toutes puissantes
industries de l'armement c'est le coeur
du système militaro économique américain
qui a été frappée par un avion kamikazes
le département d'état la tête de
l'omniprésente diplomatie américaine
c'est ici que se décide dans une large
mesure l'avenir du monde une voiture
piégée il ya explosé
vent de panique aussi dans le saint des
saints du pouvoir américain la maison
blanche
évacués de crainte d'un attentat
aucun des symboles de la démocratie
américaine n'a été épargné dans cette
journée de terreur
alors la réaction tout de suite du
premier des américains le président
george bush qui avait réagi à chaud
avant qu'on apprenne que le pentagone
était à son tour touché et il est
ensuite revenu s'exprimer devant les
télévisions c'était il ya quelques
instants l'écoutent
liberté elle-même a été attaqué ce matin
par des lâches sans visage mobile mais
la liberté sera défendu
des mac je veux assurer le peuple
américain que toutes les ressources du
gouvernement sont utilisés
pour sauver des vies et aider les
victimes de ces attaques
mais surtout ne vous trompez pas il y en
a acheté les états unis avaient
poursuivre et punir les responsables de
ces actes fabrice carrat brink's
à bègles je suis en contact permanent
avec le vice président
le secrétaire à la défense n'a changé
que khalid l'équipe nationale de défense
ainsi que mon cabinet
très calme nous avons pris toutes les
mesures de sécurité
pour protéger le peuple américain
l'armée américaine ici et dans le monde
a été placée en alerte maximum et nous
avons pris les précautions nécessaires
pour que le gouvernement puisse
continuer son travail
nous sommes en contact avec les
responsables du congrès
et les leaders mondiaux je suis pour les
assurés que nous ferons tout ce qui est
nécessaire
pour protéger
l'amérique et les américains
je demande à tous les américains
de se joindre à moi c'est dire un grand
merci à tous ceux qui sont en train de
se battre pour sauver nos citoyens
et je redemande de prier pour les
victimes
et leurs familles
dans le genre le sort de notre grande
nation et testé et spain d'acheter
mais ne vous trompez pas nous montrerons
au monde que nous passerons ce test que
dieu vous bénisse
voilà dans un instant donc retour en
direct à washington et à new york et
puis on évoquera aussi bien sur les
problèmes de sécurité et les pistes du
fbi a et d'abord on va voir que cette
déferlante terroristes à une onde de
choc dépasse largement les frontières
américaines on va faire le tour des
capitales européennes dans un instant
d'abord l'impact en france une réunion
d'urgence s'est tenue à l'elysée et à
matignon ce soir on va en parler on va
en parler avec vous aussi alain richard
ministre de la défense merci d'être avec
nous mais très rapidement jacques chirac
aussitôt la nouvelle connue avait abrégé
son voyage en bretagne
lionel jospin avait également réagi très
à chaud on écoute les deux hommes
c'est en effet avec une immense émotion
que la france vient d'apprendre ces
attentats monstrueux y'a pas d'autres
mots qui viennent de frapper les états
unis d'amérique
et dans ces circonstances effroyables
le peuple français je tiens lire ici
tout entier
est aux côtés du peuple américain
il lui exprime son amitié et sa
solidarité dans cette tragédie
j'assure naturellement le président
george bush
de mon soutien total
la france où le cvr toujours condamné
condamne sans réserve le terrorisme et
considère qu' il faut lutter contre le
terrorisme par tous les moyens
voilà réunion d'urgence à l'elysée ce
soir réunion également à matignon on
écoute de lionel jospin à l'issue de
cette réunion nous avons indiqué au
président la république des décisions
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
et notamment la mise en oeuvre du plan
gouvernemental d'alerté prévention qui
s'appelle vigipirate renforcé et puis
nous avons examiné avec lui les autres
mesures particulières qu'il pourrait
être utile de prendre éventuellement
notamment après contact avec nos voisins
français c'est un message de calme que
vous adresser ce soir où il me semble
oui mais je les dis il faut rester
attentif et en même temps être calme
gérard leclerc vous êtes en duplex de la
cour de l'elysée même tonalité à
l'elysée ce soir écouter pour l'instant
on n'a absolument aucune information sur
ce qui s'est passé sur ce qui s'est dit
ce conseil restreint auquel participe le
savez le président la république que
lionel jospin son directeur de cabinet
olivier schrameck et puis le ministre
des affaires étrangères hubert védrine
de la défense alain richard
et donc pour l'instant aucune aucune
information précise on ne sait pas non
plus si le président chirac interviendra
s'adressera aux français comme il en
était question dans l'après midi merci
gérard vous nous rappelez bien sûr dès
que vous avez de nouvelles informations
alain richard vous participiez bien sûr
à ses conseils d'urgence est-ce qu'il se
dégage ce soir le sentiment qu'une
menace plane aussi sur la france lionel
jospin s'est voulu rassurant
qu'allez-vous franchement votre
sentiment
ces attentats terroristes qui ont frappé
les états unis devant lesquels
évidemment nous exprimons une
condamnation absolue d'aussi abominable
massacres de masse
indique que nous devons prendre les
précautions c'est une prise de risque
que nous devons prendre au sérieux pour
notre pays aussi
donc notre priorité c'est la protection
du public et c'est ce qui a conduit le
gouvernement sans délai à mettre en
mettre en route le plan vigipirate
renforcé c'est à dire une présence
beaucoup plus intense de forces de
sécurité avec un soutien des forces de
la défense dans le maximum de lieux
publics le choix de ces lieux et des
points sensibles qui feront l'objet
d'une protection particulière va se
faire par les procédures normales des
situations d'urgence dans les heures qui
viennent nous allons travailler ce soir
on y reviendra en images dans un instant
mais vous dites précaution ça n'est
qu'une précaution c'est à dire qu'il n'y
a pas de menace particulière qu aurait
reçu la france on sait et on en parlera
dans quelques minutes que des menaces
avaient été adressées aux états unis cet
été oui nous sommes évidemment en
contact et en échange permanent avec les
principales nations qui peuvent être
concernés par ces phénomènes nous avons
eu les expériences de d'atteindre
terroristes contre notre propre
population donc nous sommes dans une
attitude de veille et de précaution qui
a des périodes de monter nous sommes
dans une de ces périodes vous avez vu
ces images comme nous et ce que les vous
les avez vus avec effroi c'est à dire
avec le sentiment qu'un cran avait été
franchi dans la violence terroriste et
que beaucoup de choses désormais pouvait
sembler possible aux terroristes oui ces
actes-là suppose une puissance
d'organisation qui est en effet un
bouleversement par rapport aux actions
terroristes qu'on a observé encore ces
dernières années elles vont donc
demander de notre part un travail
d'investigation et d'analysé particulier
nous y sommes déjà et bien sûr ce
travail va être partenariale entre
toutes les nations concernées ça
signifie que vous ne pensiez jusque là
que de telles opérations était
inenvisageable
notre travail est évidemment de balayer
en permanence des possibilités plus ou
moins lointaines
c'est il faut le dire vraiment au
plafond de ce qu'on a pu imaginer comme
forme d'action
concerté de destruction collective merci
alain richard d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on va faire le point
maintenant sur la réaction des
américains en france la stupéfaction et
l'incrédulité sophie mais elle andré
sera
dans un instant
la réaction de ces américains qui ont
découvert ces événements à la télévision
alors ce sera dans un instant on va
retrouver tout de suite en duplex avec
nous etienne leenhardt à washington
notre correspondant etienne on a le
sentiment que c'est le coeur de
l'américain qui a été touché
oui david ce pays ce matin c'est cet
arrêté de vivre cette date du 11
septembre restera sans doute comme l'une
des dates les plus noires de l'histoire
des états unis c c'est difficile de
décrire les scènes que j'ai pu voir ce
matin mais je me trouvais juste à
l'extérieur du ministère de la défense
le pentagone quand cette explosion s'est
produite juste à côté de l'aéroport de
washington et j'ai vu des militaires des
hommes des femmes sortir complètement
hébété de leur bureau en se demandant ce
qu'il se passait ensuite j'ai voulu
revenir au centre de washington il y
avait une panique assez indescriptible
parce que tout le monde et a été évacué
des immeubles fédéraux vous savez qu'il
y en a de très nombreux à washington et
les gens se se scotche est littéralement
aux vitrines pour regarder les écrans de
télévision pour essayer de voir pour
essayer de comprendre il est bien
évidemment beaucoup trop tôt pour
essayer de comprendre quoi que ce soit
l'opinion américaine tente d'abord
d'avoir des informations sur le nombre
des victimes ensuite sur la situation
exacte sur les responsabilités exactes
on aimerait ici dans l'opinion que le
président george bush puisse revenir à
washington il n'a même pas pu revenir à
washington et ce territoire qui était
réputée inviolable vous savez qu'il ya
eu des menaces terroristes qu'il y a eu
le world trade center certes mais que la
plupart des actes terroristes contre les
états unis ont été commis à l'extérieur
des états unis et bien ce territoire
désormais n'est plus un viol et cela
restera vraisemblablement pour pour
plusieurs générations et tiennent
peut-être des précisions sur ces avions
qui ont été détournés trois d'entre eux
donc ont été précipités sur les
bâtiments on a vu ces images le world
trade center et le pentagone
d'autres avions apparemment ont été
détournés et se sont écrasés aux états
unis qu'en est il exactement
absolument notamment un avion qui s'est
écrasé tout près de la ville de
pittsburgh et on ne sait pas encore à
vrai dire on ne sait pas encore si cet
avion a été victime dans la panique
générale qui s'est emparée des autorités
de l'aviation civile américaine a été
victime donc d'une erreur d'aiguillage
ou s'il y avait véritablement dans ce
don ce quatrième avion s'il y avait un
pirate ou plusieurs pirate de l'air à
bord c'est encore tout cela d'une
extrême confusion il me paraît encore
bien hasardeux de tirer quelques
conclusions que ce soit à l'heure qu'il
est en tout cas cela pourrait laisser
supposer que l'opération envisagée était
encore plus importante que celle qui a
été effectivement réalisées on va voir
maintenant précisément comment
réagissent les américains qui ont appris
la nouvelle qui ont vu ces images de
paris reportage donc sophie mais elle
est andré sera
la cathédrale américaine de paris a
fermé ses portes précipitamment
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas de fils
seule consigne s'occuper du drapeau non
pas pour le mettre en berne mais pour le
retirer purement et simplement par
mesure de sécurité
on fait simplement un geste qui semble
le bon geste vert ce soir
à l'université américaine le drapeau a
déjà été retirés la nouvelle vient de
retentir l'accès des lieux est interdit
à toute personne étrangère à prétention
on va fermer plus tôt et on va demander
que tous les étudiants disperser et
rentrent chez eux parce que vous
pourriez être la cible aussi d'un
attentat y siègent
compréhension
de rester groupé ensemble
pourtant l'envié de se retrouver
ensemble pour encaisser le choc est la
plus forte ce bar américain du quartier
de l'opéra est devenu l'un des multiples
points de ralliement des touristes de
passage le plus dur est d'être ici et
pas là bas quand il ya une tragédie
comme celle ci vous voulez être chez
vous c'est une chose terrible c'est
choquant surréaliste absolument horrible
je suis dévastée
et le plus terrible pour eux c'est de ne
pas avoir de nouvelles des leurs les
lignes téléphoniques avec les états unis
sont trop encombré seule la télévision
permet de garder un contact ici pleine
nuit sera longue voilà on fait un peu
l'aller retour entre les etats-unis et
la france pardonnez-nous journal un peu
bousculé vous en comprenait bien sûr les
raisons alors on évoquait avec alain
richard il ya un instant cette mise en
place renforcement d'un plan vigipirate
on va en voir tout de suite le détail
avec eux yann fronty et patrick desmet
caire
les démineurs arrivent à toute vitesse
ici au coeur de paris un colis suspect a
été signalé
la station de métro châtelet et évacués
et des grilles en bouche l'entrée scène
quasi identique un peu plus loin dans la
capitale du desrosiers au coeur du
quartier juif de paris une alerte à la
bombe et c'est tout le périmètre qui est
bouclée fausse alerte finalement les
policiers repartent bredouilles des
policiers sur le pied de guerre le plan
vigipirate vient de rentrer en vigueur
une mesure exceptionnelle prise après
les attentats perpétrés aux états unis
et qui inquiète les parisiens rencontrer
aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant hallucinant
moi je suis resté vraiment sous le choc
c enfin j'attends les représailles
maintenant pas ce qui va se passer c'est
voilà ça me fait vraiment flipper
c'est complètement hallucinant si on se
produire c'est quelque chose qu'on
pouvait
ils ont tellement redouté mais on peut
pas penser ça arriverait un jour s'est
fait peur pour votre propre sécurité
directement non ça me euh non
directement non sa maîtresse le principe
chauffe vraiment aller très très loin à
la tour eiffel les touristes américains
eux sont effrayés
je suis très choqué de cette femme c'est
une honte je me sens très triste que la
planète en arizona pour éviter que
pareil drame se produise en france le
plan vigipirate a donc de nouveau été
mise en place une première depuis la
guerre du golfe en 1991 policiers
militaires vont désormais renforcé les
contrôles dans les lieux publics aux
abords des ministères ou encore dans les
gares et les aéroports
voilà et comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays d'europe précisément les vols vers
les états unis ont été suspendus
aujourd'hui certains avions ont même
fait demi tour en vol on retrouve à
roissy yasmina farber yasmina
yasmina ferveur est ce que vous
m'entendez
alors petits problèmes de son et bien
nous retournons à washington où nous
sommes maintenant en liaison avec
philippe gassot vous avez vécu vous ces
heures de panique complète et notamment
le bombardement du pentagone est-ce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui effectivement le
sentiment que l'invulnérabilité
américaine même si elle avait été un peu
ébréché auparavant c'est désormais du
passé
on a considéré je crois en 1993
lorsqu'il ya eu un attentat au world
trade center que c'était une sorte de
numéro zéro une opération qui avait
avorté et l'opinion publique avait
rapidement passer la main et on savait
ici aux etats unis on le disait on me
répétait dans les journaux il y avait
une sorte de suprématie américaine face
aux problèmes du monde ici nous sommes
dans le pays du monde le plus puissant
le pentagone c'est l'entité militaire la
plus puissante du monde et les
américains étaient convaincus jusqu'à ce
matin que washington n'était pas une
cible même potentielle pour les
terroristes
même chose pour washington or pour new
york ce matin j'ai pu me promener à vélo
parce que maintenant les rues sont
bloquées derrière moi vous avez la
maison blanche mais cette maison blanche
est devenu une sorte de camp retranché à
plusieurs centaines de mètres de la
maison blanche vous avez des voitures
des cyclos et de services vous avez le
fbi vous avez ces fameuses bandes jaunes
qui barrent les rues et la maison
blanche est totalement isolé du reste du
monde alors pour pouvoir passer vous
débrouiller sur les trottoirs si vous
les approchez du pentagone c'est la même
chose il n'y a plus de voitures qui
circulent le périmètre de sécurité est
énorme et vous apercevez dans la rue par
exemple de cette ville qui grouillent
quand même de fonctionnaires tous les
jours au moment du repas notamment les
terrasses de café sont pleines de monde
et là vous vous promenez il ya plus
personne il ya plus perdre ya plus une
personne à la terrasse des cafés vous
avez dans m street qui est une des rues
les plus passantes de washington nous
avait j'ai compté ce matin 10 personnes
au maximum philippe est ce que vous avez
des informations sur les dommages qu'ils
auraient été constatés au pentagone est
ce que le centre nerveux de l'armée
américaine a été vraiment atteint est-ce
qu'on a des informations là-dessus ou
pas du tout assorti ce que ce qu'on
disait ce matin c'est qu'au moment où
l'impact a eu lieu sur le pentagone un
millier de personnes étaient déjà au
travail donc on peut imaginer que les
victimes vont être extrêmement
nombreuses il faut aussi des comptes et
malheureusement les victimes des
passagers qui se trouvaient dans les
avions et ici on pense que derrière tout
cela il ya plus qu'une poignée de
terroristes la dimension est trop
importante pour que l'on vise tel ou tel
groupuscule maintenant on parle
pratiquement à mots couverts d'un
terrorisme d'état on va en parler
effectivement dans un instant et antoine
basbous nous à rejoindre l'évoqué avec
vous d'abord à côté de vous philippe
vous avez anthony blinken qu'on connaît
bien en france parce que vous parlez
parfaitement le français vous avez été
un conseiller de bill clinton donc
associer étroitement aux affaires de
l'état est ce qu'il n'ya pas ce soir
tout de même le constat d'une faille
importante dans le dispositif de
sécurité et dans l'exposition au risque
des états unis
anthony blinken est-ce que vous
m'entendez alors on a un souci anthony
blinken voilà il nous entend tony
blinken je crois bonjour je vous
demandais s'il y avait il n'y avait pas
selon vous ce soir aussi un traumatisme
dû au fait qu' il y avait peut-être eu
une faute une faute de vigilance dans le
dispositif de sécurité des etats-unis
une faute qui aurait permis cette
déferlante terroristes
écoutez toutes ces conclusions sont
beaucoup trop prématuré c'est tout
d'abord une tragédie humaine
nous avons devant les yeux il faut faire
face à cette situation des vies qui ont
été perdues j'ai des gens qui sont
blessés nous avons beaucoup de temps
après pour faire un constat pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui s'est passé qui est
responsable si les eu des problèmes de
vigilance ou non mais ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour l'ordre du jour c'est de
faire face à la tragédie humaine vous
même où étiez vous au moment de ces
attentats
je mentais un peu près deux blocs de la
maison blanche ici à washington au
travail dans un institut de recherche
est gelé sur tout d'abord par les
informations à la télévision
mais j'ai des tas d'amis qui travaillent
là pentagone des amis qui sont au world
trade center à new york nous essayons
tous de prendre contact avec nos amis
avec nos familles c'est pour ça que
c'est déjà dans un premier temps c'est
une échelle humaine qu'il faut
comprendre c'est tragédie par la suite
nous pourrons savoir qui est responsable
et quelle réponse à prendre mais dans un
premier temps c'est des vies qui ont été
perdues des gens qui ont été blessées
des familles des mères des pères des
filles des enfants qui ont été atteints
est ce que ces scènes d'apocalypse
hanter vos cauchemars à vous habite
clinton lorsque vous étiez aux affaires
à la maison blanche
oui c'est quelque chose qui était à
l'esprit c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement américain depuis des années
et c'est de prendre des dispositifs non
seulement pour éviter évidemment ce
genre d'attentât mais aussi pour avoir
des plans de réponses si hélas
l'attentât a lieu c'était quelque chose
qui était tout à fait à l'esprit de
l'administration précédente tout comme
l'administration présente mais vous
savez tous les jours le gouvernement
américain a les informations sur des
attentats qui sont prévus soit disant
c'est très difficile de faire le triage
de savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui n'est
pas vrai et nous vivons dans un monde où
la grande force de nos sociétés
démocratiques
l'ouverture de la communication du
transport des voyages est également il
faible à ces normes alors vous dites on
en parlera plus tard mais simplement
d'un mot est ce que vous pensez ce soir
qu'il y a des moyens d'empêcher un tel
scénario de se réaliser c'est à dire un
détournement d'avion qui servira ensuite
deux bombes d'avion suicide
il y a toujours moyen de faire mieux est
ce qu'on peut dire que nous aurons des
succès à 100% je pense que c'est
quasiment impossible il ya eu des d'état
fin d'êta il ya eu des attaques qui ont
été
qui ont été arrêtés d'avançon ne le sait
pas parce que c'est pas publics mais
avoir du vin sur vin là dessus ce n'est
pas évident mais c'est sûr qu'on peut
faire mieux qu on va faire mieux pour
éviter de ce genre la catastrophe à
l'avenir merci anthony blinken d'avoir
été avec nous on va maintenant à
jérusalem pour évoquer les pistes et
d'abord peut-être le contexte de cet
attentat chacun pense bien sûr au
contexte du proche-orient d'ailleurs
aussitôt la tente a connu de nombreux
palestiniens ont manifesté leur joie une
revendication une revendication du fdlp
l'une des composantes dur du fatah de
yasser arafat a été rendue publique
sitôt ces attentats commis elle a
ensuite été démentie charles avec quel
regard at on assisté à ces attentats à
jérusalem
d'abord en israël l'espace aérien était
fermé à tous les vols venant de
l'étranger l'armée de l'air et en état
d' alerte le cabinet de sécurité il
réunit non pas sur la base
d'informations précises mais parce que
les israéliens parts de la thèse que
pour les islamistes israël et les états
unis sont mis dans le même sac cela dit
cette campagne terroriste ne doit pas
surprendre tout le monde j'ai rencontré
il ya quelques semaines un responsable
européen d'un grand service de
renseignement kim exprimait ses craintes
que la sphère du proche orient ne
finisse par faire tache d'huile en
europe aux états unis et me disait-il la
cia les services de renseignement
américains n'ont pas l'air de prendre
tout cela au sérieux alors on ne pense
pas que c'est comment l'éditeur de ces
attentats venaient du coeur du
proche-orient du conflit israëlo
palestinien mais probablement de la
périphérie et on pense également qu'il
s'agit probablement de foot le nombre
d'appels le terrorisme d'état oui donc
pas de piste en tout cas du côté des
mouvements palestiniens c'est donc du
côté d'oussama ben laden que se tournent
les regards ce soir oussama ben laden du
nom de ce milliardaire d'origine
saoudienne qui a été hébergé par
l'afghanistan plus connu sous le nom du
superviseur richard binet
barre dieu est grand et ces palestiniens
sont contents ils manifestent bruyamment
leur joie après les attentats de new
york et washington
[Applaudissements]
cet après midi porte de damas
qu'est ce qu'on fait il faut qu'on
arrête depuis quelques années on voit
ben laden partout à kaboul avec les
talibans au soudan au yémen en
tchétchénie ou au kosovo ces photos sont
parmi les plus récentes de ben laden
prise en afghanistan elle montre
l'islamiste en compagnie d'un maul la
taliban responsable d'une école
coranique
l'homme ne cache pas son amitié avec le
terroriste
qui recherchent cette heure alors je ne
vais pas vous donner le détail sur cette
rencontre sinon les américains vont
lancer des raids pour compte et
partout où flottent l'étendard vert de
l'islam combattants ben laden est
présent ou influents l'homme est
immensément riche 300 millions de
dollars une fortune mise au service du
jihad la guerre sainte il y a quelques
années il disait à la télévision je
recommande le meurtre partout où cela
est possible de tous les américains
civils ou militaires
voilà il est 20h30 dans quelques
secondes avant d'aller plus loin si vous
prenez ce journal en route on va refaire
un point complet sur cette opération
terroriste sans précédent à new york à
washington mais l'inquiétude est
générale dans tout l'occident daniel
wolfromm
donc le commentaire de ces églises mais
par la télévision américaine le boeing
et ses dizaines de passagers percute en
une trajectoire parfaite le haut de la
tour du world trade center vingt minutes
plus tôt un premier appareil s'était
encastré dans l'une des deux tours
jumelles provoquant déjà un terrible
incendie
c'est la panique il est 9h ce matin et
des milliers d'employés sont déjà au
bureau
[Applaudissements]
certains appellent à l'aide d'autres
préfèrent se jeter par les fenêtres
les deux boeing détourné avec leurs
passagers ont été volontairement dirigé
par les pirates versés tours symboles de
la puissance financière américaine une
heure plus tard même scénario à
washington un troisième appareil
s'écrase sur le pentagone cette fois ci
le ministère de la défense
le cerveau militaire des etats unis
presque simultanément à new york une des
deux tours s'effondrent sur elle-même
110 étages 300 mille tonnes d'acier de
béton
vingt minutes plus tard
explosion et destruction complète de sa
soeur jumelle
images d'apocalypse
le sud de manhattan
disparaît sous la poussière
[Applaudissements]
le maire de new york fait évacuer le sud
de la ville et parle d'un nombre
terrible de victimes sans avancer le
moindre bilan
bilan impossible à établir pour
l'instant les états unis pays coupé du
monde les aéroports sont fermés les vols
à destination de la france ont été
interrompues comme dans beaucoup
d'autres pays du monde on retrouve alors
précisément à roissy yasmina farber
yasmina
oui bien la tension est extrêmement
perceptible même ici à roissy à
l'instant des forces de l'ordre nous ont
demandé d'évacuer les lieux parce qu'il
ya un bagage abandonné par ailleurs on a
vu tous ses ressortissants américains
qui devaient rentrer chez eux et qu'ils
ont appris dans l'aérogare ces terribles
événements qui était survenu dans leur
pays j'en ai vu beaucoup les yeux rougis
très choqué des gens qui tremblaient des
gens qui seraient confortées malgré tout
tout se passe quand même dans une
certaine sérénité
les compagnies aériennes oriente les
passagers vers des hôtels qui sont aux
abords
de l'aérogare de roissy tous les vols
ont donc été annulées air france annulé
sept vols et sept vols ont retroussé
chemin ont fait demi tour il était parti
entre 11h et 15h cet après midi donc
tous les vols restent annulés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
yasmina alors à nice maintenant
précisément réaction de passagers
détourné entre guillemets il était en
partance pour new york pour d'autres
destinations américaines ils ont appris
la nouvelle dans l'avion olivier théron
sur place le vol delta air lines dl 83
dû rebrousser chemin il a quitté nice en
début d'après-midi et vers 17 heures
alors qu'il survolait les costes la
nouvelle est tombée l'espace américain
est fermé les 184 passagers en majorité
des américains sont donc revenus à nice
à leur arrivée ils ont appris la
terrible nouvelle
toys 'r' c'est un désastre la vie a
changé tout est changé maintenant
l'amérique apprendre qu'elle est très
vulnérable
une cellule d'assistance psychologique a
été mise en place pour prendre en charge
les passagers traumatisée par la
nouvelle ceux qui ont des amis ou de la
famille à manhattan
notre grosse difficulté c'est que les
liaisons vers les états unis les yeux
téléphoniques sont extrêmement encombré
et donc ces personnes souhaitent tout
d'abord téléphoné avec leurs familles et
ont beaucoup de mal à les joindre donc
on essaye de faire de notre mieux pour
libérer des lignes organiser l'accès aux
différents téléphones et puis être un
peu à l'heure dans la tente de leur
souhait et puis nous nous gérons pour
eux bien sûr la réservation de chambres
d'hôtel ce genre de choses les abords de
l'aéroport et le centre de carburant ont
été mis sous la protection de l'armée le
plan vigipirate renforcé est entrée en
vigueur à nice et on vient d'apprendre
que tony blair le premier ministre
britannique a interdit tous les vols
commerciaux au dessus de londres alors
on va bien sûr évoqué maintenant les
hypothèses à plusieurs spécialistes aux
gens autour de cette table je voulais
présenter dans un instant d'abord un
dernier détour un nouveau détour plus
tôt par washington nous y reviendrons
bien sûr plusieurs fois dans le courant
de cette édition spéciale un nouveau
détour par washington pour faire le
point sur les blessés au pentagone après
l'attentât donc par avion suicide le
point avec julien moment un ruban jaune
pour écarter les curieux les abords du
pentagone à washington au vite pris des
allures de poste médical avancé
les premiers blessés sortent du siège du
ministère de la défense hébétée selon
des témoins un avion de ligne s'est
écrasé sur le pentagone
une heure après la traque du world trade
center
immédiatement ce haut lieu de
l'administration bush a été évacué à
l'heure actuelle un incendie ravage
encore toute une partie du bâtiment
impossible de connaître le nombre des
victimes en ce mardi le ministère
étaient pleins ce centre névralgique de
la défense américaine emploie 24 mille
salariés une cible en plein coeur de la
capitale fédérale du coup tous les
autres bâtiments officiels ont été
aussitôt fermés
voilà dernières informations cette fois
en france on apprend que jacques chirac
va faire une déclaration solennelle
à 21h dans moins de 25 minutes bien sûr
à suivre en direct sur notre antenne un
petit tour de table messieurs pour vous
présenter vous demander votre premier
sentiment antoine basbous vous êtes
directeur de l'observatoire des pays
arabes françois heisbourg vous êtes
directeur de la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique
xavier raufer vous êtes professeur à
l'institut de criminologie à paris tours
de table rapide est ce que pour vous
l'hypothèse oussama ben laden ce soir
est la plus plausible en toi il ya un
faisceau de présomptions qui pèse
beaucoup sur oussama ben laden c'est
d'abord lui qui avait attaqué en février
93 le world trade center c'est lui qui
est à la tête d'une multinationale
islamistes capables de frapper
simultanément de coordonner plusieurs
frappes sur l'objectif au cycle aussi
complexes que sont new york et
washington françois heisbourg même
sentiment même sentiment et j'ajouterais
qu'il me paraît assez peu vraisemblable
qu'un état normalement constitué ait pu
participer de façon significative à
l'organisation de ces attentats pourquoi
quart des américains remonteront la
filière le plus ou moins rapidement mais
là remonteront et l'état qui se
trouverait impliqués dans cette affaire
subirait un sort qui ne serait guère
enviable ceci est l'équivalent de pearl
harbour a qu'un bilan une inclus l'ourcq
parleurs bourrin les 2400 morts limbourg
il a fallu quatre ans pour aller jusqu'à
tokyo les américains n'ont pas fait la
guerre zéro mort ni pour ce qui les
concerne ni pour ce qui concerne les
gens contre lesquels ils se battaient
donc je crois plutôt effectivement un
groupe non étatiques n'ayant pas un
territoire et rigolard défendre et quand
on des groupes non étatiques vous pensé
au groupe de sa marraine plat parce que
c'est le plus gros le plus important
celui qui a priori à la logistique et
les moyens de faire ça xavier raufer
même sentiment un peu différent j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu un événement
déclenchant extrêmement grave qui a été
l'assassinât ciblé par les israéliens d'
abu ali mustafa le chef du front
populaire pour la libération de la
palestine on a vu à l'enterrement de la
boue à l'immense talent du fplp c'est
simple on a vu à l'enterrement d' abu
ali mustafa
des scènes extraordinaires tous les
groupes islamistes qui en temps
ordinaire déteste le fplp qui est
majoritairement composée de palestiniens
chrétiens étaient là on a le sentiment
que c'est ce jour là qu'une une espèce
d'union sacrée s'est formée et
n'oublions pas que pour un groupe
terroriste un acte comme celui qui est
en train de se dérouler en ce moment
sous nos yeux c'est un an de travail
pour 1000 personnes y avait donc des
choses qui étaient en préparatifs depuis
longtemps et qui a eu un événement
déclenchants et on a l'impression que
c'est celui là mais celui-ci ne vit ça
signifie que vous pensez que c'est
l'organisation de cette déferlante
terroriste a pu être le fait de groupes
palestiniens où vous pensez aussi que ça
n'a été que le déclencheur mais que
l'opération a été assurée par oussama
ben laden ses proches c'est une
opération qui dépasse les capacités d'un
groupe tout seul quel qu'il soit on a
l'impression qu'un train s'est formé
avec plusieurs wagons attachés les uns
aux bouts des autres et qu'à la suite de
quoi on a pu monter cette opération là
si je peux ajouter une chose une chose
il ya eu un précédent le précédent s'est
déroulée en 1994 aux philippines on a
découvert à ce moment là que l'homme qui
était à l'origine du premier attentat
contre le world trade center qui sape et
ramzi youssef avait préparé une
opération n'a trouvé tous les documents
les disques durs sur les ordinateurs et
cetera l'opération en question visait à
capturer une dizaine d'avions gros
porteurs et à ce moment là allait
précipiter tous dans la mer et à tuer
les passagers d'une dizaine de gros
avions américains techniquement
l'opération qui vient d'être hélas
réussi aujourd'hui ressemble assez fort
à celle qui avait été préparé en 94 par
ramzi yousef auteur du premier attentat
en février 93 contre le vent le traiter
un tel scénario avait déjà donc été
envisagées on va voir ce qu'il en est
pour les états unis ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'amérique est frappée
sur son sol on revient sur les
précédents avec olivier cardon
pas besoin d'être un terroriste
déterminée pour pénétrer un espace
aérien sensibles ou interdit aux états
unis la preuve c'était il ya sept ans
jour pour jour dans la nuit un avion de
tourisme monomoteur s'est écrasé à
washington à quelques mètres du bureau
du président américain à la maison
blanche l'acte désespéré d'un pilote
voulant apparemment se suicider à new
york comme sur tout le territoire
américain tous les avions en vol sont
identifiés et connus des tours de compte
dans les cockpits une balise émet un
signal particulier très suivie au
décollage comme à l'atterrissage
c'était le cas pour les deux avions de
cet après-midi sauf que dans le cockpit
les pilotes n'étaient pas seuls aux
commandes
la seule chose dont on peut être sûr
c'est que ça ne s'est pas préparé la
veille on ne forme pas un pilote même
pour dérouter un autre pilote dans une
opération aussi lourde pour former un
pilote c'est minimum deux à quatre ans
maintenant forcé un pilote de ligne ou
un commandant de bord à aller
volontairement se mettre dans un
immeuble ça me semble peu crédible donc
malheureusement je n'ai des hypothèses
en france et notamment au dessus de
paris depuis cet après midi le
dispositif de sécurité aérienne est
passé en phase de vigilance les moyens
d'intervention de l'armée de l'air ont
été renforcées quatre patrouilles soit
une dizaine d'avions de chasse sont
prêts à décoller en deux minutes l'armée
de l'air est relié en permanence avec
l'elysée et matignon tout ceci en plus
du dispositif classique de surveillance
tous les dispositifs de du de sûreté
aérienne sont basés sur les mêmes
concepts il s'agit d'avoir des moyens au
sol voire envol dans certains cas de
détection des aéronefs
les moyens militaires ont des
spécificités dans ce domaine mais il y a
tout un réseau maillé de radars et c'est
le cas en france où s'y connecter avec
l'aviation civile qui nous permet
d'étendre ses capacités de détection
c'est ce qu'on appelle le maillage
destinée à avoir une couverture
détection la plus complète possible dans
les textes le survol de paris est
interdit au dessous de 2000 mètres mais
pour les experts français il serait
présomptueux d'affirmer qu'on pourrait
éviter à coup sûr la tragédie qui a
touché new york
voilà ça n'était pas bien sûr les
attentats aux états unis mais ce sujet
sur la protection du territoire français
face à de telles attaques nous permet de
comprendre qu'effectivement il faut une
logistique très développé vous parliez
de 1000 hommes pendant 1 an xavier
raufer antoine basbous vous avez
l'impression aussi que c'est une
opération comme ça elle est forcément
préparé depuis plusieurs mois et avec
une logistique très importante
bin laden a l'habitude d'espacé ces
frappes mais de frapper très fort
rappelez-vous 95 arrêt à 2,96 à rabat
contre les américains et puis 98 contre
les deux ambassades américaines à
nairobi et adhère et à dar es salaam et
puis l'année dernière en octobre 2000 il
a frappé lui s est cool c'est à dire un
bâtiment de guerre à aden au yémen donc
ils annoncent ils dans sa littérature il
avait dit le grand satan ce sont les
états unis suivis de la grande bretagne
et d'israël voilà qui sont mes
adversaires qui jacky je vais m'attaquer
il a dit il y à une alliance judéo
croisé qui colonisent le territoire
sacré de l'islam en arabie il faut les
en chasser ccc pardonnez moi
l'expression un peu triviale c'est le
mobile c'est le mobilis et la situation
brouillard et le mobile il y as pour bin
laden bobines l'adel une doctrine la
mecque est occupé par les américains
parce qu'ils ont des bases en arabie il
faut les en chasser et puis al aqsa est
occupée par les juifs il faut les en
chasser il y a des précédents les
américains ont fui le vietnam et ont fui
beyrouth en 83 ils ont fui la somalie et
700 dans son discours dans ses
argumentaires et du coup on va les
attaquer pour les faire fuir et c'est ça
il cherche l'humiliation il veut donner
du moral aux islamistes et il faut pas
confondre islamistes et islam et
musulmans mais pourquoi aujourd'hui
alors que bien sûr il ya ce regain de
tension au proche orient mais j'allais
dire si cette opération demande une
préparation de plusieurs mois c'était
bien avant qu'elle a été décidée
françoise boulet je vais dire cette
opération est d'un tout autre ordre que
tout seul qui ont précédé en a franchi
alors on a franchi un vrai seuil on est
passé du terrorisme à l'hyper terrorisme
c'est le premier acte d'hyper terrorisme
dans le monde c'est un basculement
d'ordre stratégique
encore une fois le bilan humain sur un
nettement plus lourd que celui de pearl
harbour qu'il parallèle qui génère 2013
on vous le répète actuellement le
parallèle qui est fait et à juste titre
les etats-unis se mobiliseront
d'ailleurs j'en suis certain en
conséquence et à que ce soit bin laden
ou d'autres il a fallu beaucoup de temps
pour organiser cette opération il y aura
dans la recherche des responsabilités
ennemis sur la sellette de la chaîne du
renseignement aux états unis les
services de renseignements sur lesquels
les américains dépensent à l'eau près
d'un milliard de dollars par an le
retour sur investissement aujourd'hui
n'apparaît pas très vite mais pour vous
le mobile françois heisbourg la raison
pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi comme ça il a fallu beaucoup de
temps pour l'organiser bin laden ah si
j'ose dire un vieux contentieux avec les
etats-unis dans douanes de smooth a
rappelé parfaitement a rappelé
parfaitement les termes et c'est bien
pour cela que je pense qu'il s'agit d'un
groupe non étatiques qu'il ému que par
des impératifs idéologique et non pas
par des enjeux territoriaux ou des
enjeux de pouvoir politique seul un
groupe de ce type là peut oser franchir
ce type de papier
pour le millénaire et l'envoyer deux
hommes deux algériens bien le canada
pour frapper atlanta ils ont été
capturés et depuis ils continuent à
affiner son son mode opérationnel et là
elle a réussi un très grand coup à
laurent boussier est avec nous en duplex
de londres laurent vous avez des
informations parce qu'il ya là bas un
journal arabe dont un journaliste est
rentré en contact avec quelqu'un qui
connaît bien oussama ben laden
absolument je ne sais pas si ce sont des
informations mais c'est en tout cas une
piste le rédacteur en chef du journal
alcott qui quelqu'un qui semble avoir
ses entrées auprès de oussama ben laden
a rencontré il ya quelques jours un
journaliste pakistanais qui appartient à
la chaîne de télévision middle east
broadcasting qui est une chaîne
saoudienne ces journalistes pakistanais
auraient rencontré oussama ben laden
début juillet vous avez mis laden qui
lui aurait affirmé je cite qu'il lui
aurait annoncé par donc pas affirmer
mais annoncée des actes à des attaques
spectaculaires qui toucherait les
intérêts américains encore une fois
c'est une information à prendre avec un
petit peu de recul mais en tout cas
c'est certainement une piste parce que
ces journalistes sont des gens qui
normalement sont assez bien informés
particulièrement sur oussama ben laden
merci laurent il ya quelque chose quand
même de frappant dans cet attentat qui
va j'allais dire au delà d'une lutte
idéologique
ça ressemble au méchant de james bond de
10 ans à des besoins sur cet attentat
renvoie une folie humaine est ce que ben
laden est un fou si c'est lui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement cette
dimension-là cette dimension ou
mégalomane dans ce dans ce personnage il
ya deux constantes qu'on a tendance à
oublier la première c'est que les
conflits au moyen-orient se passe
toujours de la même manière depuis 45 ou
50 ans il y à des phases comme les
battements d'un coeur où les choses se
concentre au moyen-orient et la un
moment donné le sont bloqués alors après
ça ça explose soit à l'échelle de
l'europe soit les chefs du reste c'était
pour le mobile voilà et deuxièmement
n'oubliez pas que les terroristes issus
du moyen-orient' est toujours un nouveau
président des états unis quand il arrive
le
voilà donc à l' on est maintenant à
l'échelle plus les choses sont bloquées
au moyen-orient et plus ça explose fort
à l'extérieur on a concentré une espèce
de marmites de sorcières et maintenant
l'explosion est ce qu'on n'est pas au
delà tout ça est que cet attentat dans
sa démesure dans sa folie en somme on
est dans un comportement qui ne peut
être que le comportement d'un groupe
sans racines au sens le plus strict du
terme toutes entités étatiques doivent
veiller à des impératifs de pouvoir
éveiller des impératifs de sécurité du
territoire et les états du moyen-orient
ne sont pas plus irrationnel que
d'autres même s'ils ne sont pas
forcément plaisant mais là c'est fini
depuis la fin de la grève précisément
quand même le sol d'un terrorisme d'état
lancé philippe pittet la façon et la
façon dont les responsables de cet
attentat en tenter d'instrumentaliser
avec un certain succès hélas les
palestiniens en faisant revendiquer la
sphère initialement
faussement parle fdpl paix organisations
palestiniennes
les scènes de liesse qui s'en sont
suivies les malheureux palestiniens il
avait déjà sharon maintenant et risquent
en plus d'avoir la haine inextinguible
de la population américaine ayant
assisté à la télévision à ces scènes de
liesse jose j'ose espérer qu'elle est
responsable palestinien calmeront
maximum le jeu alors précisément antoine
basbous vous allez vous exprimer à
nouveau mais on va aller à jérusalem ont
retrouvé la mifi avi pazner l'un des
porte parole du gouvernement israélien
avi pazner est ce qu'on a le sentiment
là bas est ce que vous avez le sentiment
que c'est un attentat c'est une escalade
qui est lié au conflit proche-oriental
encore mais nous avons remarqué que
immédiatement après l'attentât un groupe
palestinien
on a clamé la responsabilité après une
heure ou deux cela a été démenti après
nous avons contacté c'est avec tristesse
que à jérusalem est des palestiniens
danser dans les rues mais tout cela ce
n'est pas une information solide pour
savoir qui est derrière ces attentats
j'aimerais juste fait remarquer que
préparer un attentat comme ça cela prend
des mois sinon des années et que
contrairement à ce qui a été dit
maintenant par un de vos commentateurs
il est peu probable qu'une décision
comme cela et puis se faire en deux ou
trois semaines cela est une affaire
préparer manigancé de longue date vous
sous-entendez que cette décision-là de
frapper de frapper de cette manière là
n'auraient pas de lien avec l'attaqué
qui avait visé le leader du fplp cette
composante du fatah de yasser arafat est
ce que vous pensez ce soir monsieur
partenaires et que le danger le danger
terroriste pour israël a monté d'un cran
le danger terroriste pas seulement pour
israël ce qui est arrivé aux états unis
et encore une fois je le répète nous ne
savons pas encore qui est derrière cette
attaque démontre que la terreur n'a pas
de logique ce qui est arrivé aujourd'hui
aux états unis est tout simplement
monstrueux et démesurée par tous les
critères humains et cela peut
malheureusement arriver pas seulement
israël mais dans d'autres pays aussi si
on ne prend pas les mesures nécessaires
pour combattre le terrorisme
vous avez proposer votre aide aux états
unis est ce que cela signifie que vous
avez des pistes des moyens de connaître
un peu plus sur ces groupes et notamment
sur l'entourage d'oussama ben laden donc
nous avons proposé notre aide par un
mouvement spontané de solidarité et
d'amitié de compassion envers les états
unis et nous avons maintenant déjà des
équipes de sauvetage prêt à s'envoler
vers les états unis dès qu'ils auront
reçu le feu vert ça ne veut pas dire que
nous avons une piste sur qui a fait cela
mais ça veut dire que nous aimerions
aider nos amis américains dans cette
heure de détresse et dans cette
tourmente dans laquelle ils se trouvent
et nous voulons faire tout notre
possible pour faciliter la situation des
blessés et de tous ceux qui ont été
atteints par spectacle merci monsieur
pas l'air d'avoir été avec nous en tout
cas cette piste elle est officiellement
privilégiée c'est ce qu'indiquent les
agences de presse par le fbi a et la
piste tout ça m'a ben laden on y revient
maintenant sur ses précédents
terroristes aux états unis olivet caroff
donc nous les rappelle
l'amérique avait mis longtemps à oublier
ces images c'était il ya près de huit
ans à l'entrée du world trade center un
peu après midi la fumée et la panique
l'ecri l'attentât une demi tonne
d'explosifs dans une camionnette bilan
six morts un millier de blessés
rapidement boucler lé enquête permettra
d'arrêter les quatre auteurs de cette
attaque à la bombe des terroristes
originaires du moyen-orient ils seront
condamnés chacun à deux cent quarante
années de prison
arrêté et condamné à son tour leur chef
omar abdelrahman il dirigeait une
organisation intégriste égyptienne sa
folle ambition détruire des lieux
symboliques de new york comme le siège
des nations unies vidéo à l'appui le fbi
y avait au moins pu déjouer le complot
de ses apprentis terroristes islamistes
mais la sphère n'a pas tardé à inspirer
d'autres criminels
19 avril 95 oklahoma city un camion
piégé et ventre cet immeuble des
services fédéraux l'administration
américaine jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était
l'attentât le plus meurtrier de
l'histoire du pays 168 victimes cette
fois c'est un ancien jihai décorés
pendant la guerre du golfe qui a commis
l'attentât
timothy mcveigh a été exécuté en juin
dernier les états unis s'en rende compte
leur territoire est à la merci de
n'importe quelle folie meurtrière
tragique confirmation un an plus tard
une bombe déposée dans la foule en plein
jeux olympiques d'atlanta tue une
personne en blesse six autres les
mesures de sécurité étaient pourtant
draconiennes il faudra deux ans pour
trouver le coupable l'un des dix
criminels les plus recherchés à l'époque
depuis toute la politique américaine de
lutte antiterroriste était en crise en
cible de toutes les critiques le fbi est
arrogant pour beaucoup incompétent pour
quelques-uns en juillet dernier george
bush lui a donné un nouveau directeur
robert muller devait rendre confiance
aux américains tâche difficile dans un
pays où n'importe qui peut posséder une
arme mais où personne n'a de carte
d'identité
voilà et on l'a vu cette fois il s'agit
d'une action terroriste une toute autre
ampleur on l'a dit aussi ce n'est pas
seulement les états unis qui sont
déstabilisés par cette action c'est tout
l'occident qui se sent fragilisé à
l'image des bourses qui se sont
effondrés aujourd'hui on va en parler
avec vous aussi messieurs d'abord le
point sur l'effondrement justement des
places financières aujourd'hui c'est un
thermomètre cyrille devaud
journée de deuil pour la finance
mondiale toutes les bourses américaines
sont restées fermées aujourd'hui car les
actions terroristes viennent de frapper
la capitale économique de la planète les
tours jumelles du world trade center
dominés wall street le gigantesque
quartier d'affaires
c'est donc le symbole de la puissance
financière internationale qui vient de
s'effondrer entraînant toutes les
bourses du monde dans la tournante
en france le cac 40 perd 7,4 pour cent
et atteint son plus bas niveau depuis
mars 99 en europe londres chute de 5,7
pour cent à la clôture milan de 7,8 %
francfort de 8,3 pour cent amsterdam 2
7% ce soir les spécialistes sont très
inquiets
le moral des consommateurs et la
consommation jusqu'à présent tonné la
croissance avec cet événement dramatique
à mon avis le moral des consommateurs
aux états unis et dans le reste du monde
va être attaqué et donc je pense que les
bourses vont chuter cet après midi
pendant que la place de londres et
évacuées par mesure de sécurité afin
d'éviter un krach la plupart des
cotations mondiales sont stoppés à
toronto mexico lisbonne ou sao paulo
parallèlement le marché du dollar est
suspendu pour enrayer sa chute notamment
face à l'euro la monnaie européenne se
négocie en soirée à +20 dollars 91 son
plus haut depuis fin août comme toujours
lors des catastrophes
les professionnels spécule sur les
valeurs refuge l'or gagne plus de 10% en
quelques heures et le baril de pétrole
flambe à près de 30 dollars 12 pour cent
de plus que ce matin voilà la question
est simple un françois heisbourg est ce
qu'avec cet attentat et puis ensuite on
demandera aussi son avis à christian de
boissieu économistes qu'on a on vous a
entendu déjà dans le sujet est ce
qu'avec cet attentat il y a dix ont une
perte de confiance dans la puissance
dans la capacité de maîtrise de
l'occident à assurer sa sécurité à
assurer la sécurité de son système
économique est ce que c'est ça une
montre l'effondrement des bourses
aujourd'hui l'a22 grande question qui se
pose dorénavant à nous la première
question c'est de savoir si les états
unis à la suite de l'énorme choc qu'ils
ont reçus va réagir en se mobilisant ou
si les états unis resteront prostré jeu
paris - sur la mobilisation mais la
messe n'est pas encore dite la deuxième
grande question qui se pose c'est de
savoir comment nous les européens et les
autres états de droit nous allons nous
coordonner avec nos amis américains
face à cette guerre j'emploie le terme
délibérément le sait le poids qu'il peut
avoir face à cette guerre qui a été
déclenchée par le groupe responsable de
cette opération de guerre qui encore une
fois représente un bilan supérieur à
celui de nombre de bataille de la
première ou la deuxième guerre mondiale
quand vous pensez à une riposte
simplement avant de revenir
spécifiquement à l'économie vous pensez
à quoi on fait quoi on va bombarder les
camps d'entraînement on suppose être sûr
monsieur ben laden dans le sang d'abord
de riposte j'allais dire à la clinton
avec trois missiles de croisière dans le
désert afghan ce n'est vraiment plus la
nature de ce qui va se passer les
américains je pense et agiront dans la
durée comme ils l'ont fait dans la
guerre du pacifique ou non en europe
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
nous européens comme américains nous
allons devoir faire des arbitrages
nouveau entre la sécurité et la
transparence dans nos sociétés ces
attentats a montré il faut serrer
quelques boulons c'est ça ce n'est pas
ce que je suis va sacrifier quelques
libertés pour assurer nautiques non je
ne dis pas cela je souhaite surtout pas
être mal interprétés en dix ans que je
viens de dire je dis tout simplement
comme ce fut le cas dans les conflits du
passé première guerre mondiale où
deuxième guerre mondiale nous allons
devoir trouver un ajustement harmonieux
si possible entre les nécessités de nous
prémunir contre les vulnérabilités de
nos systèmes économiques et politiques
on a vu ce qu on a vu ce que cela
représentait plus un avion qui vole aux
états unis c'est pas compliqué vous
pouvez appeler ce soir personne à
nouilhan l'espace aérien est totalement
interdit au dessus de londres
nous avons là une opération de guerre
qui a provoqué l'arrêt d'une très grande
société la société américaine a contre
cela visiblement les dispositifs
sécuritaires n'ont pas été suffisants et
les services de renseignement ont déjà
évoqué aurons des réponses apportées
seront sur la sellette très sollicité
très sollicité et on est en tout état de
cause comme nous l'avons nous constaté
en france en ce moment de la faire moi m
khalkhal y les attentes à 95 96 on va
devoir mettre en place de nouveaux
dispositifs sécuritaires j'étais
convaincu alors jacques chirac dans deux
minutes maintenant donc vous avez 120
secondes christian de boissieu pour nous
dire en quoi stratégie sécurité et
économie sont si impliqué qu'il y ait
une panique sur les marchés financiers
coûté ya la bourse dont vous avez parlé
mais je crois qu'il faut aller au delà
de la bourse ya l'économie on vient de
parler de la confiance ce qui restait de
croissance dans nos économies des deux
côtés de l'atlantique reposer sur la
confiance des consommateurs
cette affaire dramatique est
sérieuse menace est plus qu'une menace
sur la confiance des consommateurs
américains européens et c est donc je
suis persuadé que les conséquences
économiques difficiles à prévoir parce
que il faut d'abord prendre la mesure de
l'événement mais les conséquences
économiques voc risque d'être plus
importante que celle de la crise plus de
la guerre du golfe de 90 91 et je
rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit c'est à
dire que face à cette chute probable du
moral 10,1 des autres de nous tous il ya
la sécurité également je crois qu'il
faudra affirmé une gouvernance au plan
mondial c'est le problème du g7 que vont
faire les alliés que va faire l'occident
pour essayer de rétablir un peu la
confiance non seulement politiques mais
également économique dans les semaines
et dont les motifs à antoine basbous
puis ensuite on ira à berlin juste avant
d'entendre jacques chirac parce que là
aussi un bon exemple il faut savoir s'il
y a suite à ces attentats ou pas si le
terrorisme s'arrête là au pas il ya
d'autres attentats programmée il ya
encore une guerre bactériologique
parce que bin laden en est est en mesure
de lancer peut-être quelques bombes de
cette nature et puis je sais pas non
plus et plus de la science fiction non
non les américains se sont vaccinés ya
quelques années contre les effets d'une
guerre bactériologique et en depuis 98
il y avait un monsieur d'un coordinateur
de la lutte contre le terrorisme avec 3
milliards de dollars sur cinq ans pour
dépenser pour protéger les ambassades
américains à l'étranger et monsieur
clark dispose de dix mille lieues 10
milliards de dollars par an pour la
sécurité pour faire face
genre risquent donc la guerre des
étoiles on est vraiment très loin trait
à côté la finance et la sécurité
étroitement imbriqués on a le temps
d'aller à berlin précisément patrice
romedenne vous vous retrouvez vous nous
annoncez que
des mesures de sécurité particulières
sont prises pour tous les immeubles de
francfort francfort c'est la place
financière européenne
oui effectivement il faut savoir david
qu'il ya eu une alerte à la bombe une
alerte à la bombe cet après midi à la
bourse de francfort et qu'elle a été
fermée alors que préalablement dans
l'après-midi et bien on avait continué à
travailler dans cette bourse où tout le
monde regarde et tout en travaillant la
télévision il ya aussi autre chose à
francfort où la bourse a chuté
aujourd'hui il y a le salon de
l'automobile devant lequel les mesures
de sécurité ont été renforcées
ce salon de l'automobile étaient ouverts
aujourd'hui aux professionnels qui vous
l'imaginez au passé plus de temps devant
la télévision que tu as regardé les
voitures et il sera ouvert au grand
public jeudi donc que le grand public
soit rassurée si tant est qu'on puisse
l'être
les mesures de sécurité seront
renforcées autour de ce salon et ses
gardes fraudeurs et iosca fischer de
concerts qu'ils ont annoncé tout à
l'heure en faisant une déclaration à la
presse merci patrice à londres c'est
aussi à la bourse que ce sont
visiblement concentré les menaces ou les
peurs laurent boussier la place
financière londonienne a été évacué en
cours de journée c'est bien ça oui
absolument la bourse de londres a été
évacué cet après midi mais auparavant le
premier ministre tony blair avait tenu
une réunion de son conseil de défense
avec le ministre des affaires étrangères
le ministre de l'intérieur le ministre
de la défense et les chefs d'état-major
à l'issue de cette réunion plusieurs
décisions ont été prises les forces de
police et la défense anglaise ont été
mis en état d' alerte et puis
l'opération cobra a été décidée
l'opération cobra c'est le renforcement
de la sécurité dans tous les édifices
gouvernementaux civils ou militaires non
seulement à l'intérieur du royaume uni
mais aussi dans les ambassades et dans
les consulats anglais à l'extérieur il
faut savoir mais vous l'avez déjà dit
que les vols british airways ont été
annulés vers les états unis et que la
reine mère elle-même la reine par la
reine pas la reine mère la reine s'est
dit elle-même horrifiés de ces attentats
merci laurent dans un instant jacques
chirac il est 21h02 si vous nous
rejoignez juste après l'intervention
présidentielle on fera un nouveau point
complet sur les événements d'aujourd'hui
à new york à washington et dans
l'ensemble du monde on a compris qu'il y
a un vrai changement de climat ce soir
après cette déferlante terroriste sur
l'est américain la dernière minute cette
décision communiquée par le général
patrice klein à l'état major de l'armée
de l'air 10 avions de chasse français
sont prêts à décoller sous préavis de
deux minutes pour intercepter tout avion
au comportement suspect c'est ce qu'on
indique donc à l'état major de l'armée
de l'air voilà encore qui donne une idée
de l'atmosphère des craintes de
l'inquiétude qui lie à à paris comme
ailleurs dans les autres capitales
européennes est-ce qu'à l'elysée on
donne des signes de vie pour cette
nouvelle intervention de jacques chirac
intervention assez solennel pas tout de
suite alors peut-être un mot christian
de boissieu là encore sûr et bien sûr
ces places financières qui se sentent
directement visées sur 7 sur cet édifice
iconique sur ce changement de climat
vous disiez crise de confiance problèmes
de consommation oui je suis plus inquiet
de ce qui se peut se passer du côté de
l'économique du côté des bourses même si
les deux sont liés par définition mais
avant cette affaire dramatique on
parlait déjà de crac crac lent et on
parlait du risque de récession il est
possible que cet événement dramatique à
travers dix ans la chute du moral des
consommateurs est derrière eux des
entreprises nous met dans une sorte de
récession mondiale je le souhaite pas
évidemment et là on se rendra compte que
les baisses de taux d'intérêt monsieur
greenspan qui a été au fond un peu qui
nous attirait d'affaires depuis 1 depuis
un an ça va pas suffire greenspan la
baisse des taux d'intérêt n'est pas à la
hauteur de l'évènement ça c'est clair
aujourd'hui donc même si alors quand les
bourses baissent il ya toujours des
valeurs qui montent comme vous savez les
assureurs et les codes des campagnes à
sion ans monte le pétrole le prix du
pétrole est en train de flamber et donc
ça c'est également ça va tu as pas être
bon pour le moral des uns et des autres
c'est clair mais je crois qu'il faut qu'
une réponse qui soit pas uniquement
financière il faut une réponse politique
par rapport à cet événement aux
conséquences humaines mais également
conséquences économiques vous êtes
japon dray dans le sens de christian de
boissieu à se voir qu'un ce que dira ou
ce que ne dira pas solennellement la
nation américaine le président bush sera
à cet égard essentielles et à la
capacité des responsables en particulier
du g7 des principales puissances mais
d'autres aussi de la russie de la chine
sera essentiel qu'on n'est pas ici face
à un remake de la guerre du golfe ou
face à un remake des attentats de paris
de 1995 96 on a changé encore une fois
d'échelle les implications économiques
et politiques et stratégiques de cette
affaire sont plus sérieuses c'est un
basculement qui n'est pas loin d'être
équivalents au basculement que nous
avons connus pacifiquement en 89 90 avec
la chute du mur
l'intervention de jacques chirac à
l'elysée prévue à 21h à un petit peu de
retard alors dans un instant refait un
point complet un point factuelles sur ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui aux états
unis si vous rentrez chez vous d'abord
xavier raufer vous vouliez dire un mot
oui à moyen terme et à court terme on a
quand même un énorme problème de
renseignement j'étais en contact et des
responsables de la sécurité dans les
heures qui ont suivi la faire c'est
arrivé complètement sans aucune espèce
de signes avant-coureurs et donc la
première des remises en cause et la plus
immense et la plus gigantesque au mode
juillet quand j'étais aux états unis
j'ai rencontré des responsables de la
sécurité il avait une obsession une
fixation sur bin laden mais à l'étranger
il était certain qu'un attentat allait
se produire en dehors du territoire
américain là c'est une surprise une
mauvaise surprise de nature absolument
catastrophique nul ne s'imaginait ya
quelques semaines encore qu'un attentat
de cette ampleur pourrait se produire
sur le sol des états unis et j'allais
dire vu les gens que j'ai rencontrés à
l'époque même pas dans les services de
renseignement américains là aussi il y
aura des remises en cause nous évoquions
en test depuis 15 heures maintenant et
sans s'en pose cet attentat hors du
commun
dans l'est américain à new york à
washington des cibles très symbolique
visait en attendant l'intervention de
jacques chirac et si vous rentrez chez
vous un nouveau point donc sur les faits
avec
avec didier wolfrum
l'image est terrible presque irréelle en
direct filmée par la télévision
américaine le boeing et ses dizaines de
passagers percute en une trajectoire
parfaite le haut de la tour du world
trade center vingt minutes plus tôt un
premier appareil s'était encastré dans
l'une des deux tours jumelles provoquant
déjà un terrible incendie
c'est la panique il est 9h ce matin et
des milliers d'employés sont déjà au
bureau
[Applaudissements]
certains appellent à l'aide d'autres
préfèrent se jeter par les fenêtres
les deux boeing détourné avec leurs
passagers ont été volontairement dirigé
par les pirates versés tours symboles de
la puissance financière américaine une
heure plus tard même scénario à
washington un troisième appareil
s'écrase sur le pentagone cette fois ci
le ministère de la défense le cerveau
militaire des etats unis
presque simultanément à new york une des
deux tours s'effondrent sur elle même
110 étages 300 mille tonnes d'acier de
béton
[Musique]
vingt minutes plus tard
explosion et destruction complète de sa
soeur jumelle
ouais
images d'apocalypse
le sud de manhattan
disparaît sous la poussière
[Applaudissements]
le maire de new york fait évacuer le sud
de la ville et parle d'un nombre
terrible de victimes sans avancer le
moindre bilan alors question questions
techniques y at il des moyens d'empêcher
ce genre de détournement ce genre
d'opération terroriste avec nous
françois grangier vous êtes pilote de
ligne syndicat national des pilotes de
ligne si je ne m'abuse non expert en cas
d'accident expert en cas d'accident
pardonnez moi vous êtes en tout cas bien
sûr spécialisée dans ces questions y at
il un moyen ce scénario at il déjà été
envisagée en france et y at il des
moyens d'y faire face un avion de ligne
un avion de transport civil est un avion
qui sert en menait déjà en vacances pas
du tout à faire face à un acte de guerre
donc si depuis les années 70 c'est le
début des détournements on a
effectivement mis en oeuvre des moyens
que l'on appelle des mesures de sûreté
pour pallier au problème de l'exciter
qui par une action individuelle voudrait
effectivement nuire à une entreprise ou
un gouvernement est bien et l'aviation
de ligne ne s'est pas du tout du tout du
tout adapté à des un état de guerre et à
un acte organisé le fruit vraisemblable
hand de plusieurs dizaines de personnes
peut-être même centaine
vraisemblablement avec des complicités
un armement un matériel des finances
donc en fait une arme et un avion de
ligne ne peut absolument pas résister à
un tel acte il n'y a pas de solution il
n'y a pas de solution dans les aéroports
à l'embarquement
pour faire face à ce genre de ce genre
de scénario la seule solution serait de
n'accepter personnes à bord des avions
comme ça on serait sûr effectivement
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'intervention mais
dans ce cas là ce n'est plus un acte
commercial ce n'est plus une aviation de
ligne c'est une aviation militaire si
effectivement on veut éviter ce genre
d'actes il faudrait que pour protéger
les pilotes il y ait tout de suite une
escouade de commando en force devant
l'entrée du poste de pilotage et encore
ça règlerait le problème du détournement
mais peut-être pas de la bombe
vous aviez déjà vous même envisagé une
telle opération non aussi vaste aussi
large un pilote de ligne est quelqu'un
qui part serein de sa préparation des
vols il a pallié à tout problème
technique tout problème d'organisation
il ne va pas se mettre à penser à de
telles choses pour lui les mesures
préventives sont un acte quotidien qui
consiste effectivement à à éviter
d'avoir à penser à ces choses une fois
qu'on est en l'air donc si l'ensemble
des mesures sont correctement prise on
évacue complètement le risque habituels
je dirais c'est à dire le petit
détournement la face à une telle
organisation
il est dans l'impossibilité de réagir il
faut se rendre compte que si ces avions
ont percuté les immeubles c'est qu'on
les a dirigés précisément sur ces
immeubles
donc il l'a fort à parier que l'on a
évacué du poste de pilotage les pilotes
soit en leur faisant croire qu'un autre
équipage mal intentionnés certes mais
pas autant aller diriger l'avion vers un
aéroport ou une prise d'otage classique
serait faite soit qu'on a carrément
assassiné ses pilotes dans leur poste de
pilotage de manière à ce qu'ils ne
gênent pas pour la trajectoire mais en
tout cas vous pensez que les pilotes de
ses avions n'était pas aux commandes un
pistolet sur la tempe ou une menace
quelconque lorsque les avions se sont
encastrées dans ces deux twins towers je
suis commandant de bord donc il est
clair que si un jour quelqu'un me
demandait à faire le choix entre un
immeuble et une balle de revolver vu
l'échéance qui est quasiment identique
je préférais la balle de revolver au
moins j'aurai peut-être l'assurance que
que l'avion n'irai pas fabrice fin
n'irai pas à percuter un endroit où
plusieurs milliers de gens risqueraient
en plus de mourir ce sont les
terroristes même qui ont donc dû prendre
les commandes selon toute vraisemblance
selon toute vraisemblance oui il y avait
quelqu'un d'autre qu'un pilote aux
commandes on va donner le bilan quand
même il ya quatre avions impliqués ce
sont les deux compagnies américaines qui
l'indiquent 2 166 victimes et parmi
elles 45 ha en pennsylvanie où l'un des
quatre avions s'était écrasé alors lui
effectivement n'a pas touché de cible là
on peut penser que le pilote aurait fait
disons la résistance et aurait précipité
son appareil dans cette zone boisée qui
ne présentait aucun risque pour éviter
de rentrer dans une cible qui aurait pu
entraîner plus de victimes eh bien deux
hypothèses soit effectivement il ya eu
combat dans le poste de pilotage qui a
entraîné la perte de contrôle de
l'appareil soit l'équipage qui a pris
les commandes n'avait peut-être pas
assez d'entraînement pour maintenir la
vie en ligne de vol ouais alors les
mesures de sécurité particulières on l'a
vu le plan vigipirate est réactivée
mesures de sécurité dans les aéroports
reportage florence griffon alexandre le
grand a roissy sur donc ces nouvelles de
mesures de sécurité que vous allez
constater vous même dans les jours qui
viennent si vous prenez l'avion
ils ont appris la nouvelle alors qu'il
survolait l'océan atlantique direction
seattle washington au meilleur coût ces
voyageurs sont pour la plupart
américains les compagnies qui les
transportait american airlines ou air
france
ces raisons l'espace aérien est fermé ce
qui parmi eux ont l'habitude de voyager
la technique que quelque chose de très
risqué qu'il y avait des gens l'avion
qui comme moi travaillent dans wall
trade center et qui se sont un peu
désolé mais le personnel de bord a bien
maîtrisé les choses
la direction générale de l'aviation
civile a décidé d'annuler tous les vols
à destination des états unis cet avion
d'air france ont donc fait demi tour
l'urgence ici rentrer chez soi ou
trouver un hôtel
battant le prochain voit quand je sais
pas
et qu'est ce qu'on vous propose
visiblement rien qui sont aussi des ils
sont débordés donc et pourtant air
france a bien décidé d'employer les
grands moyens des bus et des taxis
appelés en renfort mais aussi des
équipes de soutien logistique cette nuit
les hôtels parisiens auront une
clientèle américaine imprévus
voilà un numéro que communiqués par le
ministère des affaires étrangères le
quai d'orsay si vous souhaitez de plus
amples renseignements sur les
possibilités ou pas vous rendre aux
états unis pour l'instant c'est
impossible aéroports américains fermés
vol à direction des états unis a
supprimé en france et dans beaucoup de
capitales européennes 01 45 55 80 00
pour tous renseignements c'est une
cellule de crise qui est mise à votre
disposition on apprend à l'instant sin
toujours de cette tension perceptible et
joue parler des avions de chasse
français qui étaient placées en état d'
alerte et bien on apprend que l'otan est
en état d' alerte maximale
on rejoindra tout à l'heure à bruxelles
christian mary mono puisque le siège de
l'otan qui se trouve dans la capitale
belge a été partiellement évacuée
également pendant la journée une
dernière précision françois granger vous
me disiez que ce n'est pas la première
fois que des opérations de ce type sont
menées même si les objectifs visés
n'étaient pas les mêmes vous faisiez
allusion aux années 70 oui tout à fait
le 6 septembre 70 ça a été une journée
noire pour l'aéronautique il y a eu une
demi-douzaine de détournement anisé l'un
marquant un boeing 747 de la compagnie
panam donc des intérêts américains
encore amsterdam qui a terminé en feu
sur l'aérodrome du caire et deux autres
qui ont terminé dans le moyen-orient sur
un aérodrome désaffectée avec une prise
d'otage et la demande très ferme de
libération de prisonniers en échange des
otages et c'est cette journée noire qui
a marqué la le début de ces mesures de
sûreté qui sont prises maintenant pour
éviter les détournements autrement dit
il y a des précédents même s'ils ne sont
pas exactement du même type est-ce que
nous pouvons aller à bruxelles retrouver
christian mary mono pour cet état d'
alerte des troupes de l'otan pas tout de
suite est ce que jacques chirac est prêt
à prononcer son allocution à l'elysée
pas tout de suite et bien je vous
propose maintenant de revenir peut-être
sur les précédents terroriste puisque on
évoquait 1970 avec vous les précédents
terroristes dans le monde depuis une
trentaine d'années c'est le grand réveil
du terrorisme bernard lebrun sur ses
précédents
il était écrit que les avions ces
morceaux d'état volant seraient les
cibles favorites des terroristes
moyen-orientaux sur cet aéroport
désaffecté dans le désert jordanien il
ya tout juste 31 ans un boeing américain
un dc-8 suisse et un dc10 britannique
était vidée de tous leurs passagers et
dynamité tel déjà des symboles
l'action terroriste quant à la fin de la
guerre des six jours en 1967 les armées
coalisées du monde arabe sont battus par
israël il en est fini des espoirs du
peuple palestinien de retrouver sa terre
c'est alors que le fatah et les fedayin
l'alarmé de l'organisation de la
libération de la palestine olp de yasser
arafat passe à l'acte
tout d'abord en jordanie dont les
combattants palestiniens sont chassés
par les troupes du jeune roi hussein
septembre noir pour les palestiniens
commencent dès lors le deuxième exil
vers le liban
septembre noir sera le nom du commando
palestinien qui pénètrera devant toutes
les caméras du monde dans le village
olympique
prenant pour otage une partie de
l'équipe israeli and bilan onze
israélien assassiné la france non plus
ne sera pas épargné en 1980 une bombe
explose près de la synagogue de la rue
copernic
bilan trois morts 20 blessés
[Applaudissements]
changement de tactique sur le sol
libanais entre en scène les conducteurs
kamikaze au camion bourré de dynamite
241 soldats américains trouvent la mort
dans ces décombres un an après toujours
en septembre c'est la tour du drakkar
l'immeuble qui abrite les français bilan
de ce deuxième camion suicide 24 morts
96 blessés
toujours les intérêts américains cette
fois c'est dans une discothèque
berlinoise que sont frappés les troupes
de l'otan accusé les services secrets
libyens
dès lors les états unis d'amérique de
vienne en dehors de l'état d'israël la
cible privilégiée des attentats
moyen-orientaux à l'étranger base
militaire américaine en arabie saoudite
380 blessés accuser le saoudien bin
laden ambassades américaines de nairobi
et de dar es salaam en tanzanie même
accusé et tout récemment au corps au
yémen dans le port d'aden tout un
symbole en cette fin de millénaire un
vulgaire canot pneumatique bourré de
dynamite pilotés par des islamistes
suicidaire temps en frappant la coque de
couler un croiseur de la sixième flotte
américaine
on a des précédents mais de l'avis de
tous un cran a été franchi aujourd'hui
avec cet attentat bonsoir nicolas vous
êtes politologue spécialiste des états
unis c'est aussi votre sentiment rien ne
sera plus jamais comme avant dans les
relations entre les états unis et le
reste du monde et la perception
qu'auront les états unis leur propre
écrite rien ne sera plus jamais comme
avant de toute façon il ya déjà des
points de non retour et les pages
d'histoire qui s'inscrivent on me
demande souvent combien de temps il faut
pour se remettre combien de temps il
faut pour que la page se tournait une
page comme ça ça se tourne pas ça se
tournent pas dans une génération en gros
on a parlé en fait alors à cause de
l'ampleur de cette vague terroriste à
cause du traumatisme que cela suscite si
vous êtes amis à cause du nombre j'en
suis à moitié vous êtes dans un pays qui
est un continent on vous répète la
géographie vous le monde vos professeurs
vous apprennent à l'école vous êtes à
l'abri s'il reste du monde va mal
retirons nous un petit peu à l'intérieur
de notre continent on a des ressources
naturelles on a tout ce qu'il nous faut
on est les plus puissants a le plus
d'argent c'est un peu naïf mais c'est
comme ça que ça que ça fonctionne tout
d'un coup c'est plus vrai tout d'un coup
les images que vous voyez à la
télévision qui se passe à jérusalem et
tel-aviv qui sont dramatiques sont
terribles elle se passe chez vous et
encore empire dont vous n'êtes plus à
l'abri et c'est ça que c'est ce qui
bascule on lit souvent est-ce que les
américains vont redevenir isolationniste
ils ne sont pas parce qu'ils ne peuvent
plus l'être le monde du 21e siècle n'est
plus un monde où les américains peuvent
se retirer mais bien un paradoxe quand
même dans la situation d'aujourd'hui
c'est que l'administration bush n'était
pas particulièrement proches c'est le
moins qu'on puisse en dire deux du
gouvernement de tel aviv on a eu un
flottement assez puissant les intérêts
américains à l'heure actuelle vu par
bush sont quand même c'est vrai tous
l'accès au pays les états unis sont
malgré tout considéré depuis longtemps
et il ya des raisons pour cela comme des
alliés sûrs d'israël or finalement une
action terroriste
elle dessert toujours la cause qu'elle
prétend défendre si on apprend que ce
que cette attente à ses attentes à
défendre la cause palestinienne ce qui
n'est même pas encore certain qu'elle
résultat cela pour les palestiniens
c'est qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
américain nous sommes tous des
américains je serais très étonné que le
président chirac disent autre chose et
tous les leaders occidentaux quand on
dit on est avec vous on est tous ces
américains sa radicale issa simplifie
les opinions publiques et finalement
derrière contre un ennemi très vague
très flou et très injustement désignés
qu'est l'islam grosso modo brève mais
alors vous parliez d'isolationnisme
alors selon vous ce choc qu'il y avait
états unis va faire que l'administration
bush pas plus se préoccuper de ces
conflits sur des théâtres étrangers ou
au contraire il va y avoir un repli je
ne pense pas qu'il puisse le mans puis
je pense que l'option n'existe pas même
si on peut même si certains américains
peuvent le souhaitez d'abord parce que
là il se passe une situation que
américain ne maîtrise absolument pas ils
vont chercher à la maîtrise et chercher
à la maîtrise et ça veut dire intervenir
l'étranger d'une manière que je ne
connais pas et vous probablement non
plus mais en tout cas ça va les
impliquer à l'extérieur il s'agit
certainement du proche orient et il
n'est plus possible que les américains
ne s'y intéressent pas et on peut
supposer qu'ils ne vont pas être
particulièrement bienveillants à la
cause arabe son ensemble ce qui prouve
l'absurdité d'un acte donne acte de
cette nature avec encore une fois la
prudence qui convient ce soir puisque
absolue n'est pas une maison pas
seulement de relier cet attentat
attribué aux proches d'oussama ben laden
à la situation au proche orient parce
qu'on ne peut pas l'attribuer aux petits
gamins qu'on a vu se réjouir dans la rue
ils sont élevés dans un fanatisme certes
bon ils ont vu les images à la télé et
qui ressemble à rambo et sont contents
c'est pas quand c'est pas eux qui sont
rentrés en avions dans les tours et en
plus on a évidemment une redéfinition du
rôle des alliés par exemple au sein de
l'otan même des relations avec la russie
parce que poutine vladimir poutine a
fait savoir immédiatement qu'au fond ils
sentaient pas à l'abri non plus on va
retrouver gérard leclerc dans un instant
en direct à l'elysée simplement un mot
vous disiez je suis à moitié américaine
oui j'imagine vous connaissez très bien
sérieux vous connaissez travers les plus
tôt vers le world trade center j'imagine
que voilà et moi j'ai fait comme tout le
monde j'ai appelé j'ai appelé les lignes
les lignes téléphoniques sont surchargés
je sais que ma famille à washington y
vont bien à new york j'ai pas réussi à
les joindre et c'est terrible c'est bon
c'est personnel ce que je vous dis en
même temps des centaines de milliers de
gens le partage vous voyez une ville qui
est la vôtre imaginait la tour eiffel
qui s'effondre à côté de la tour
montparnasse grosso modo voilà vous avez
été très choqué on s'extasie extra nous
gérard leclerc en duplex de la cour de
l'elysée où s'est tenue tout à l'heure
un conseil d'urgence un conseil
restreint et où on attend une
intervention de jacques chirac
gérard avez vous des informations d'une
minute à l'autre est en train de faire
les derniers réglages techniques que
jacques chirac le président chirac qui a
préparé cette intervention dans le bus
dans son bureau avec le secrétaire
général dominique de villepin jacques
chirac qui vous savez cet après midi
vers 18h30 avec convoquer un conseil
restreint avec le premier ministre
lionel jospin le ministre de la défense
le ministre de l'intérieur le ministre
des affaires étrangères des ministres
qui s'étaient auparavant retrouvés à
matignon avec le nahd jospin et qui
avait décidé le déclenchement d'un plan
vigipirate renforcé avec notamment une
surveillance
sur les lieux publics les aéroports les
gares les bâtiments publics et dans le
même temps on apprenait également
reprenait un peu plus tard que des
avions de chasse sont prêts intervenir
en cas de détournement d'avion voilà on
attendant que cette intervention je
pense tout le monde s'attend à ce que le
président chirac condamne de nouveau
très fermement bien sûr ces attentats
qu'il a qualifié de monstrueux qu'il
exprime la solidarité de la france avec
le peuple américain et puis qu'il donne
des explications j'ai rarement les
mesures de sécurité qui sont je ris
essayez les attentats qui ont frappé
aujourd'hui
les états unis d'amérique
sont une épouvantable tragédie le jamais
aucun pays dans le monde a été la cible
d'attentats terroristes d'une telle
ampleur ni d'une telle violence
je veux redire au peuple américain la
solidarité de tous les français dans
cette dramatique est probable
nous conseillerons temps particulier à
toutes les victimes à leur famille à
leurs proches
ce qui s'est produit aux etats-unis nous
concerne tous
j'imagine les sentiments que chacun
d'entre vous et prou ce soir sentiment
d'horreur et peut-être d'inquiétude et
j'ai pensé qu'il était de mon devoir de
vous parler
nous ne connaissons à ce stade ni les
auteurs ni les raisons de ces actes
barbares
la situation requiert néanmoins sang
froid mais aussi vigilance et
mobilisation
c'est pourquoi j'ai réuni ce soir à
l'elysée un conseil restreint avec le
premier ministre et des ministres des
affaires étrangères de la défense de
l'intérieur des transports
les mesures de précautions qui
s'imposent ont été prises immédiatement
par le gouvernement et le plan
vigipirate que vous connaissez et mis en
oeuvre
nous agissons avec le premier ministre
bien sûr en étroite concertation et
évidemment tous les pouvoirs publics
sont mobilisés
par ailleurs je suis en tact avec les
responsables européens afin que nos
décisions soient bien coordonnées je
viens en particulier de m'entretenir
longuement avec le chancelier allemand
schoder et le premier ministre
britannique tony blair
la france c'est qu'on ne peut lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme
que par une action
déterminée et collectives et elle fera
ce qui doit être fait
voilà jacques chirac nous sommes tous
concernés dit le président la république
qui confirme ce sentiment diffus qu'on
sent un peu partout dans les capitales
européennes que cette vague de
terrorisme qui a touché les états unis
fragilise un peu l'occident tout entier
revenons revenant la situation à new
york donc une demi douzaine d'heures
après les explosions et on va voir tout
de suite que les recherches continuent
dans les décombres des deux tours du
centre d'affaires de wall street agnès
vahramian
voilà tout ce qu'il reste des 110 étages
de la tour du world trade center
ce sont les premières images prises sur
les décombres la caméra filme comme un
automate s'approche au plus près de
l'acier du béton enchevêtrés des
plafonds des planchers empilés comme
lors d'un tremblement de terre devant
cet amas les pompiers quasiment hébété
préviennent d'abord les risques
d'éboulements ou d'explosion gaz
aucun bilan fiable pour l'instant sur le
nombre de victimes des milliers de
personnes étaient déjà au travail ce
matin
ce secouriste visiblement son chapeau
peine à expliquer qu'il a bien vu
quelqu'un de vivant dans les ruines la
personne est ensuite mort
au détour d'une rue la roue d'un avion
celui qui s'est crashé bien sûr posé là
comme un vestige de la catastrophe la
zone est fermée au public ni parce que
quelques habitants à la recherche de
leurs proches toute la nuit les secours
vont chercher des survivants
[Musique]
image irréelle de new york aux couleurs
de la cendre si vous nous rejoignez les
21h28 édition spéciale consacrée bien
sûr à cette déferlante terroriste à new
york et à washington dans un instant on
sera en duplex précisément avec un
témoin qui a assisté à la scène un
journaliste français il nous racontera
tout simplement puisque on a une minute
françois heisbourg vous êtes toujours
avec nous j'aimerais revenir sur une
déclaration de la soirée celle du régime
en place en afghanistan celle du régime
des taliban qui déclare nous condamnons
ces attentats nous n'y sommes pour rien
on sait qu'oussama ben laden qui est
montré du doigt à ce soir par toutes les
capitales occidentales et par le fbi à y
est protégé entre guillemets par le
régime des talibans alors est ce un
double langage c'est plus compliqué que
ça un ben laden et ses hommes
représentent une force réelle en
afghanistan et il n'est pas tout à fait
certain que le gouvernement des talibans
puisse le j'allais dire de faire
déménager
s'il le voulait vraiment il est vrai
aussi que je crois que les talibans
mesures assez bien ce qui risque de leur
arriver si le moindre élément de
complicité devait être devait apparaître
et même si aucun élément de complicité
ou verte devait apparaître il risquerait
malgré tout de leur arrivée des choses
fort désagréable de quels moyens de
pression dispose oussama ben laden sur
le régime des talibans les la galaxy ben
laden en afghanistan
c'est ainsi plusieurs milliers d'homme
fort bien armé dans un dans un pays où
les groupes bien armés certes
fleurissent mais celui là a une cohésion
et un savoir faire dont hélas nous avons
eu l'occasion d'apprécier c'est souvent
les méfaits
les relations taliban ben laden c'est
pas une affaire simple
les talibans c'est pas simplement un
cache sexe de ben laden les talibans ce
sont des dires des gens fort peu
fréquentables qui viennent d'ailleurs de
tenter d'assassiner le principal
opposant à
massoud
mais les talibans sont tout aussi gérant
d'un état d'un pouvoir qui risque fort
d'être compromis à la suite de ces
attentats s'ils devaient être retracés
vers l'afghanistan
21h30 retour au fait le détail le
déroulement de cette journée le
déroulement de cette vague terroriste
aux etats unis les dernières images
montées commentait thierry kurt et
cercle et à gauche le deuxième avion
détourné le boeing kamikazes visent et
s'écrase sur la tour encore intacte
l'avion de ligne n'a pas dévié d'un
mètre ils frappent la tour en son milieu
le wall trade center se trouve au sud de
manhattan à deux pas de wall street dans
le quartier des affaires
18 minutes avant un premier avion de
ligne détourné lui aussi s'est crashé
sur la première des deux tours jumelles
l'opération a été parfaitement minute et
quarante minutes plus tard washington un
troisième avion vient s'écraser sur le
bâtiment le plus stratégique des états
unis d'amérique le pentagone le siège du
commandement militaire puis on apprend
qu'un quatrième avion un 747 également
détourné s'est écrasé près de pittsburgh
les quatre appareils provenaient de
trois villes différentes
il transportait 2 166 personnes à new
york les deux avions transformé en
missile ont percuté les deux tours au
moment de l'arrivée au bureau des 50000
personnes qui travaillent au world trade
center vers 9h ce matin des dizaines
d'employés font des signes désespérés
d'autres choisissent de sauter par les
fenêtres
les deux bâtiments jumeaux mesure 410
mètres de haut
mais les deux tours véritable monument
dédié à l'économie américaine ne vont
pas résisté bien longtemps la première
se brise par le milieu bascule et ses
fonds
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième implose et s'écroule
chacun des deux bâtiments pèse près de
300 mille tonnes située au bord d'une
rivière d'un côté mais adossé au
quartier des affaires de wall street de
l'autre le maire de new york parle donne
l'effroyable bilan sans avancer le
moindre chiffre l'aef à l'aviation
civile américaine décide de fermer tous
les aéroports des états unis plus un
avion civil est autorisé à voler les
trains doivent rester en gare les
frontière avec le mexique sont fermées
l'amérique est paralysé
voilà les dernières nouvelles en
provenance des états unis la flotte
américaine de l'atlantique a dépêché des
porte-avions à washington et à new york
afin de protéger je suit les centres
nerveux politique et financier du pays
après donc cette série d'attentats des
porte avions américain pour protéger les
centres nerveux les centres de décisions
américain george bush réunis en ce
moment le conseil de sécurité américains
au centre de commandement du nebraska à
la tension est donc extrême la
mobilisation aussi on va leur écoute et
george bush sa réaction c'était peu
avant 20h
liberté elle-même a été attaqué ce matin
par des lâches sans visage elle fait
l'amour et de la liberté sera défendu
des mac je veux assurer le peuple
américain que toutes les ressources du
gouvernement sont utilisés
pour sauver des vies et aider les
victimes de ces attaques
mais surtout ne vous trompez pas
les états unis avaient poursuivre et
punir les responsables de ces actes
fabrice carrat brink's
à bègles je suis en contact permanent
avec le vice président le secrétaire à
la défense n'a choqué khalid l'équipe
nationale de défense ainsi que mon
cabinet
nous avons pris toutes les mesures de
sécurité
pour protéger le peuple américain
l'armée américaine ici et dans le monde
a été placé en alerte maximum et nous
avons pris les précautions nécessaires
pour que le gouvernement puisse
continuer son travail
nous sommes en contact avec les
responsables du congrès
et les leaders mondiaux je suis pour les
assurés que nous ferons tout ce qui est
nécessaire
pour protéger
l'amérique et les américains
je demande à tous les américains
de se joindre à moi et dire un grand
merci à tous ceux qui sont en train de
se battre pour sauver nos citoyens
et je leur demande aussi de prier pour
les victimes
et leurs familles
le sort de notre grande nation et testé
et speedcast
mais ne vous trompez pas nous montrerons
monde qu'on nous passerons ce test que
dieu vous bénisse
mais les états unis blessé il faut dire
que ces cibles n'ont pas été choisies au
hasard le world trade center c'est le
symbole de la puissance économique
commerciale financière
de wall street et des états unis dans
leur ensemble le pentagone s'est bien
sûr le saint des saints le siège de
l'armée la plus puissante du monde on
revient sur ces deux cibles et aussi sur
le département d'état où un attentat à
la voiture piégée a été commis
également dans la journée jérôme
baugnies
la splendeur américaine frapper là où ça
lui fait le plus mal dans sa puissance
financière d'abord dont les tours
jumelles du world trade center était le
symbole de tour construite en 1973 d'une
hauteur de 400 m qui dépasse celle du
veillant par state building c'est tour
du centre mondial du commerce
appartenait aux autorités portuaires des
états de new york et du new jersey elle
hébergeait 500 compagnies
internationales cinquante mille employés
c'était aussi un haut lieu du tourisme
qui attirait chaque mois deux cent mille
visiteurs
aujourd'hui l'un des fleurons de new
york est parti en fumée
autre cible le pentagone le centre de
commandement de la première puissance
militaire mondiale plus de vingt mille
personnes y travaillent c'est ici qu'est
contrôler une puissance de feu comme le
monde n'en a jamais connu 5700 charges
nucléaires sans compter des liens
étroits avec les toutes puissantes
industries de l'armement c'est le coeur
du système militaro économique américain
qui a été frappée par un avion camille
le département d'état la tête de
l'omniprésente diplomatie américaine
c'est ici que se décide dans une large
mesure l'avenir du monde une voiture
piégée il ya explosé
vent de panique aussi dans le saint des
saints du pouvoir américain la maison
blanche
évacués de crainte d'un attentat
aucun des symboles de la démocratie
américaine n'a été épargné dans cette
journée de terreur
oui confirmation à l'instance c'est ben
laden qui est bien soupçonné
officiellement par les états unis c'est
ce qu'indique à un responsable américain
qui est vraiment oussama ben laden
réponse en images dans un instant
d'abord thierry thulliez vous nous
rejoignez re bonsoir et vous attiriez
notre attention sur les réactions des
capitales arabes oui effectivement on a
un peu l'impression d'un vide que devant
l'énormité de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui aux états unis bien les peas
haras prennent un peu leurs distances
effectivement on sait que yasser arafat
le président de l'autorité palestinienne
à 10 ont dénoncé cet attentat on sait
que le hamas mouvance islamiste qui est
située à gaza et bien a dit ne rien
avoir à faire avec ces attentats on
vient d'apprendre que la syrie donc le
pays voisin d'israël la syrie condamne
ces attentats aux états unis c'est
l'agencé officielle sana qui l'annoncent
donc on voit bien que la l'énormité des
opérations finalement de guerre qui
s'est déroulé aujourd'hui qui se sont
déroulées aujourd'hui sur le sol
américain et bien font que les pays
arabes prennent leurs distances par
rapport à d'éventuels les organisations
terroristes qui pourraient revendiquer
ces attentats il ya une volonté de se
démarquer
oussama ben laden il a 44 ans ses
apparitions sont très rares son portrait
donc signé bertrand cocq
pour les américains c'est le diable en
personne ousmane ben laden milliardaire
saoudien et chef terroriste le fbi a mis
le classe parmi les dix personnes les
plus dangereuses de la planète les
etats-unis lui attribue la
responsabilité des attentats contre leur
ambassade en 98 au kenya et en tanzanie
224 morts depuis quelques années on voit
ben laden partout à kaboul avec les
talibans au soudan au yémen en
tchétchénie ou au kosovo ces photos sont
parmi les plus récentes de ben laden
prise en afghanistan elle montre
l'islamiste en compagnie d'un maul là
responsable d'une école coranique
l'homme ne cache pas son amitié avec le
terroriste
manquée recherche cet homme alors je ne
vais pas vous donner de détails sur
cette rencontre sinon les américains
vont lancer des raids pour contenir
partout où flottent l'étendard vert de
l'islam combattants ben laden est
présent ou influents l'homme est
immensément riche 300 millions de
dollars une fortune mise au service du
jihad la guerre sainte il y a quelques
années il disait à la télévision je
recommande le meurtre partout où cela
est possible de tous les américains
civils ou militaires
oussama ben laden qui serait le seul à
disposer d'une logistique
pour qui ce genre d'attentât ne poserait
pas de problème en tout cas pour qui ce
genre d'attentât serait une possibilité
c'est ce que nous indiquait nos invités
il y un instant plus que jamais c'est
lui qui fait figure de suspect numéro 1
après cette vague d'attentats c'est ce
qu'indique aussi je vous le disais des
responsables américains on va revenir
sur l'une des images incroyables
l'une des images très fortes de cet
après-midi new york dévasté des scènes
pratiquement des scènes de guerre dans
les rues avec les avions de chasse qui
survolait manhattan dans la crainte de
nouvelles attaques d'avions suicide avec
ses deux tours géantes du world trade
center qui se sont écroulés et ses
scènes de panique dans les rues et ces
témoignages rassemblés par patrick
fandio
[Applaudissements]
l'impensable vient de se produire
et c'est la panique au coeur de
manhattan
dans les rues près des deux tours du
world trade center chacun cherche un
abri
mais policiers pour ce qu'ils peuvent
[Musique]
à 7 heures ce sont des milliers
d'américains qui se rendent au travail
ou dans les centres commerciaux tout
près ce matin ils vivent le drame en
direct
l'effondrement des deux tours de verre
le long de l'hudson river
cette femme raconte qu'elle a entendu un
gros boum
et après il ya eu une grosse fumée tout
le monde a essayé de sortir et on a vu
arriver un autre avion de l'autre côté
il y avait de la fumée partout et des
gens qui ont tenté de sortir par les
fenêtres
dans les immeubles entre les débris ce
qu'ils ont pu trouver la porte de sortie
raconte l'incroyable
nous avons entendu une grosse explosion
tout est soudain devenu très sombre il y
avait des débris de verre qui tombait de
partout les gens étaient blessés c'était
une grosse explosion tout était noir il
y avait un nuage de cendres comme de la
neige mais vous le voyez ce n'est pas de
la neige c'est l'immeuble c'était un
cauchemar terme
après le crash du premier avion il y en
a eu un second ce ils venaient du sud et
a heurté la tour sud vers le haut de
l'immeuble ça ne peut être qu'une action
terroriste c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire
il ya eu une grosse explosion des gens
sont sortis à moitié dénudée et j'ai
tout fait pour essayer de les aider
c'est tout le sud de manhattan qui a été
évacué puis bouclé par des centaines de
policiers et de secouriste alors qu'un
nuage de cendres à son bric c'est
toujours la vitrine financières du monde
oui manhattan couverts par cet épais
nuage de fumée et rudolph giuliani le
maire de new york qui déclarent qu'ils
ne sera pas possible d'établir un bilan
avant au moins 24 heures et puis cette
dépêche france presse qui nous rappelle
qu'en 1945 un avion un bimoteur avait
heurté par accident cette fois
l'empiré state building qui était à
l'époque le sommet de new york
l'accident avait fait 14 morts nul doute
que cette fois on sera bien au-dessus
largement au dessus de ce chiffre il est
21h 43 si vous nous rejoignez on va
faire un nouveau rappel des faits des
événements de cet après midi avec de
nouvelles images qui nous sont parvenus
de pennsylvanie où le quatrième avion
détourné à des fins terroristes s'est
écrasé dans une forêt sans faire
visiblement de dégâts mais bien sûr de
nombreuses morts civils tous les
occupants de l'appareil en fait agnès
garder
une bombe volante un boeing 757 avec à
son bord 58 passagers vient s'écraser
sur l'une des tours du world trade
center il est 9h15 heure locale en plein
centre de new york
18 minutes plus tôt un premier appareil
a pris pour cible l'autre tour de
l'édifice
s'entête à chacune abritant bureau et
siège bancaire cinquante mille employés
s'y rendent chaque jour
accrochés aux fenêtres certains
demandent de l'aide désespérément
d'autres se jette du haut du building
pour échapper aux flammes
[Musique]
au sol c'est la panique et cela devient
l'enfer lorsque les deux tours
s'effondrent
[Applaudissements]
elles vont imploser l'une après l'autre
dans un nuage de poussière et de cendres
donnant à manhattan des allures
d'apocalypse
j'assiste à exploser l'avion se trouvait
tout était noir il n'y avait plus de
lumière seules quelques personnes
avaient des briquets et puis en plus il
y avait tellement de poussière partout
comment êtes vous senti de là à la
lumière des briquets et puis on a suivi
quelqu'un avec sa torche
tout le monde des paillettes en sang
c'est horrible
et c'est la deuxième fois pour moi
j'étais déjà là la première fois
et wall street la capitale financière ne
sera pas la seule cible le pentagone est
visé également deux explosions ont
secoué le bâtiment siège de la défense
américaine autre symbole du pays
là aussi on avance la thèse d'un
appareil détournés par des terroristes
et ce n'est pas tout à 11h30 heure
locale un boeing 747 s'écrase en
pennsylvanie entre new york et
washington
au total 4 avion qui se crashe en
quelques heures tout le pays est en
alerte
oui une opération d'une ampleur inouïe
superlatifs dans toutes les capitales
est inimaginable
hallucinant
incroyable c'est vrai que les mots
semblaient faire défaut en fin
d'après-midi pour qualifier ce spectacle
a new york et à washington alors
précisément dans les capitales
occidentales on le disait il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétude je vous rappelle
qu'à paris une dizaine d'avions de
chasse sont prêts à décoller à tout
moment il ne leur faut que deux minutes
en cas de comportement suspect d'un
avion sur le territoire français à
londres d'autres mesures ont été prises
le survol de londres le survol de la
capitale est interdite on va voir si à
berlin il règne aussi un climat
d'inquiétude avec vos patrice romedenne
qu'en est il
écouter david il ya un mot qui revient
souvent dans le vocabulaire allemand ce
mot là c'est chaos et je peux vous dire
qu'il est effectivement sur toutes les
lèvres ce soir à berlin je dirais que le
chancelier schröder lorsqu'il a pris la
parole a dit à peu près l'essentiel
lorsqu'il a dit que c'était une
déclaration de guerre contre l'ensemble
du monde civilisé il a fait cette
déclaration à la suite d'une réunion
qu'il a tenue à laquelle il avait invité
les principaux chefs des principaux
partis de tous les partis même
représenté au bundestag donc vous le
voyez il ya une sorte de refus total
d'unanimité d'union sacrée contre le
terrorisme dans le monde politique et à
laquelle fait écho aussi la rue la rue
est extrêmement choquée et
gerhard schröder le sait il a tenu à
grandir à rassurer les allemands en leur
disant qu a priori aucune menace
terroriste ne plane sur l'allemagne cela
étant dit on a appris qu'il avait un
conseil de crise qui permettait de
réagir et de coordonner d'éventuels
secours si cela devait être nécessaire
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure de nombreux bâtiments ont vu
leur sécurité renforcées il y à
l'ambassade américaine l'ambassade
israélienne le salon automobile de
francfort qui débutait aujourd'hui pour
les professionnels et qui va se
poursuivre dans les jours qui viennent
et puis certains bâtiments comme par
exemple la grande synagogue de berlin a
été a été a vu la sécurité qu'il y avait
autour renforcée voilà merci patrice oui
pas de menace particulière mais des
précautions c'est aussi le son de cloche
en france c'est ce que nous disait alain
richard le ministre de la défense il
était tout à l'heure notre invité sur ce
plateau je vous propose de re écoutez un
extrait de ses déclarations
ces attentats terroristes qui ont frappé
les états unis devant lesquels
évidemment nous exprimant une
condamnation absolue devant d'aussi
abominable massacres de masse
indique que nous devons prendre des
précautions c'est une prise de risque
que nous devons prendre au sérieux pour
notre pays aussi
donc notre priorité c'est la protection
du public et c'est ce qui a conduit le
gouvernement sans délai à mettre en
mettre en route le plan vigipirate
renforcé c'est à dire une présence
beaucoup plus intense de forces de
sécurité avec un soutien des forces de
la défense dans le maximum de lieux
publics le choix de ces lieux et des
points sensibles qui feront l'objet
d'une protection particulière va se
faire par les procédures normales des
situations d'urgence dans les heures qui
viennent ces actes-là suppose une
puissance d'organisation qui est en
effet un
bouleversement par rapport aux actions
terroristes qu'on a observé encore ces
dernières années avons donc demandé de
notre part un travail de d'investigation
et d'analysé particulier nous y sommes
déjà et bien sûr ce travail va être
partenariale entre toutes les nations
concernées ça signifie que vous ne
pensiez jusque là que de paix
l'opération était inenvisageable
notre travail est évidemment de balayer
en permanence des possibilités plus ou
moins lointaines
c'est il faut le dire vraiment au
plafond de ce qu'on a pu imaginer comme
forme d'action
concerté ou de destruction collective
voilà à l'ats richard donc il y a un
instant retourne à washington tout de
suite etienne leenhardt est avec nous en
ligne etienne je sais que
vous êtes dans la ville vous vous êtes
promenés dans la ville ces dernières
minutes ou en étant à washington quel
est l'état d'esprit quelle est
l'ambiance écouter l'avis de moody's est
un peu après 20 heures que la vie
c'était quasiment arrêté vers washington
est une ville morte à l'heure qu'il est
absolument plus personne dans les rues
les gens sont rentrés chez eux les
quartiers les plus importants de la
ville sont complètement bouclé par les
forces de police
toutes les écoles ont fermé les unes
après les autres nous sommes plusieurs
parents avoir des enfants ici à
washington et toutes les écoles ont ont
fermé pas forcément pour des raisons de
sécurité mais simplement parce que il y
à un choc national et que les
enseignants m'ont téléphoné je vous
raconte ma mon expérience personnelle
les enseignants m'ont téléphoné en me
disant est ce que vous pouvez venir
chercher vos enfants les renvoyer à la
maison nous ne pourrons plus faire dire
la place aujourd'hui peut-être pas
demain la ville est mort clé tous les
restaurants qui sont d'habitude bondée à
l'heure qu'il est aux états unis ont
fermé leur porte et le récent le mans au
moins jusqu'à jusqu'à demain matin je
vous rappelle que le président george
bush n'est toujours pas rentré dans la
capitale américaine la maison blanche
est complètement bouclé par les forces
de police il se trouve dans le nebraska
à l'autre bout du pays et
c'est les informations et les sentiments
les émotions que vous faire parvenir
jusqu'à maintenant etienne cdh george
bush n'est toujours pas rentré à
washington c'est pour des raisons de
sécurité oui en tout cas officiellement
là la réponse que l'on nous donne savait
que la sécurité qui entourent le
président des états unis
traditionnellement est absolument
draconiennes et je pense que l'on a
voulu éviter un cafouillage jeu
supplémentaire il ya déjà un début de
polémique avant même que l'émotion soit
retombée il ya un début de polémique sur
la façon dont les autorités américaines
sont en train de gérer les premières
heures de cette véritable tragédie
nationale et je pense qu'on aura d'une
part pour des raisons de sécurité et
puis ensuite peut-être pour éviter un
cafouillage supplémentaires évitez donc
de faire rapatrier le air force one
l'avion du président américain sur sur
washington je ne sais pas si vous avez
des informations à ce sujet etienne on a
appris également que des porte-avions
était rapatrié en quelque sorte vers les
états unis pour assurer la sécurité des
bâtiments publics des bâtiments où se
prenait les décisions oui il ya je crois
par deux d'émotion forcément et
d'irrationnel dans toutes ses décisions
c'est-à-dire quand je pense que les
autorités américaines veulent donner le
sentiment à l'eau cliente le clic clic
complètement terrorisé par le choc lié
une une violation de ces territoires de
cet été de sanctuaires les territoires
américains qui jusqu'à maintenant
étaient avaient été relativement
épargnés jeudi relativement par rapport
à des attentats comme le votre est un
temps relativement épargné donc par des
actes de terrorisme et donc il ya des
mesures qui dit il ont pris est ce que
est ce que ces mesures sont nécessaires
maintenant ce serait un jeu c'est un
grand débat je vous dis washington est
une ville complètement complètement
qu'il n'y a plus aucune personne dans
les mines à part de la police dans les
buildings l'immeuble fédéraux que ce
soit le ministère de la justice des
finances le pentagone évidemment qui a
été touché le département d'état et donc
c'était on a un peu l'impression d'une
ville morte une ville en même temps en
état de siège et avait tout à l'heure je
parlais avec des américains et six dans
la rue ils me parlaient de ce film qui
est sorti il ya quelques années et qui
s'appelle je crois la traduction
française est état de siège ils ont dit
on ne pensait pas que cela pouvait
arriver aux états unis bien voilà c'est
encore pire que le le film et c'est
pourtant la vérité merci etienne
l'amérique touché l'alliance atlantique
inquiète sur le qui-vive
état d' alerte à l'otan on va retrouver
christian mary monod à bruxelles les
locaux avaient été en partie évacué
dès l'après midi christian marie je
crois
tout à fait l'avis d'une partie du
personnel personnels administratifs
avaient été évacués une première dans
l'histoire de cette institution et à
l'heure qu'il est le conseil de
l'atlantique nord est réuni pour
exprimer sa solidarité avec le principal
allié les etats-unis côté commission
européenne romano prodi le président
étienne conférence de presse également
au alors qu'il est dans les institutions
européennes
et puis le premier ministre belge qui
assure la présidence de l'union
européenne différents stades a déclaré
que c'est une tragédie au niveau de la
planète avait exprimé sa solidarité
aussi au peuple américain enfin notez
que demain les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères se retrouvent à
bruxelles pour examiner ensemble les
mesures à prendre ensemble donc les 15
face au terrorisme merci christian mari
thierry thulliez on parlait tout à
l'heure des réactions des pays arabes
une réaction qu'on attendait celle de
l'iran effectivement pour l'instant ce
cas un des rares pays à ne pas avoir
réagit bien l'iran condamne les
attentats aux états unis en des termes
d'ailleurs très très vif puisque je cite
le président iranien mohammad khatami
condamne le terrorisme et c'est notre
devoir islamique d'en connaître et d'en
détruire les racines donc il se range
très clairement du côté des victimes
cette fois-ci d'ailleurs le gouvernement
irakien a présenté ses condoléances aux
familles et puis on apprend aussi israël
a décidé de fermer ses frontières
terrestres cette fois ci avec l'egypte
et la jordanie finalement israël comme
les états unis comme son grand talent
américains et bien se retrouve un peu
maintenant isolé du reste du monde son
espace aérien et bouclé ses frontières
terrestres sont également bouclé là
aussi l'inquiétude et les précautions
daniel bilalian nous a rejoint à nouveau
sur ce plateau daniel oui ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que malheureusement la
journée n'est pas encore terminée aux
états unis même si c'est la nuit déjà en
france la balle sommes simplement en
début d'après midi donc il faut se dire
sans faire d'alarmisme que les
américains ne sont pas encore totalement
assuré il peut encore se passer un
certain nombre d'événements tout peut
arriver encore cet après midi aux etats
unis je crois que c'est l'état d'esprit
qui règne actuellement c'est sans doute
pour cette raison d'ailleurs que le
président américain n'est pas rentré
dans sa capitale washington il ne se
sent pas en sécurité là-bas ce qui est
tout de même quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire l'événement bien sûr et à
la dimension des états unis mais je
pense que petit à petit on prend
conscience qu'il est à la dimension de
la planète c'est pratiquement la terre
entière qui a arrêté ses communications
aériennes israël ferme ses frontières
l'otan à bruxelles prend des mesures de
sécurité pour protéger son quartier
général on l'a entendu tout à l'heure le
président république jacques chirac est
en concertation avec les états unis
l'allemagne l'angleterre les principaux
alliés de l'occident pour essayer de
parer à toute éventualité pour tenter
d'identifier ceux qui ont perpétré ces
différents attentats je crois que on va
prendre conscience au fur et à mesure de
cette soirée et des jours qui vont venir
de ce qui s'est passé cet événement
c'est un événement qui est concerne la
planète entière
l'amérique a été touché en son coeur
mais nous sommes tous concernés
devraient simplement ajouter une
information qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut kim
a été tout à l'heure rapportés alors je
la donne avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
précaution est vraiment au conditionnel
l'avion qui a explosé quelque part dans
une forêt en pennsylvanie se dirigeaient
se dirigeraient à l'époque c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit tout à l'heure peut-être
vers une centrale nucléaire américaine
avec pour but de percuter une centrale
nucléaire américaine sur et que encore
rajouter au drame que vivent aujourd'hui
les états unis mais c'est une
information à prendre vraiment au
conditionnel et avec des pincettes
charles enderlin
avec nous en ligne on rappelait il ya un
instant on vient de l'apprendre en fait
qu'israël ferme ses frontières
terrestres avec l'egypte et la jordanie
juste avant de vous donner la parole
charles on va quand même revoir ces
images d'explosion de joie dans les
territoires autonomes palestiniens et
dans les camps de réfugiés au liban
explosion de joie à l'annoncé de ces
attentats à new york et à washington est
ce qu'on l'a cette image non ce sera
sans doute pour un peu plus tard à c'est
un sujet de richard binet qui nous qui
nous les bouffent
la wac barre dieu est grand et c'est
palestiniens sont contents ils
manifestent bruyamment leur joie après
les attentats de new york et washington
[Applaudissements]
c'était cet après midi porte de damas
dans la partie arabe de jérusalem
des manifestations similaires ont eu
lieu à naplouse ville palestinienne de
cisjordanie
selon cheikh ahmed yassine le chef
spirituel du hamas l'amérique est la
cause de bien des injustices à travers
le monde et c'est la raison pour
laquelle selon lui tout le monde éprouve
de la haine pour les états unis
finale
le front démocratique de libération de
la palestine dont on avait dit à un
moment qu'il avait revendiqué les
attentats se dément toute implication
ce responsable condamne toute action
menée contre des civils et hors des
territoires occupés par israël
enfin yasser arafat
le président de l'autorité palestinienne
a présenté ses condoléances au président
bush ainsi qu'au peuple américain
en son nom et au nom du peuple
palestinien avant de se déclarer très
choqués par ces tarés américain people
qualifié de terrible et d'effroyables
complète les chocs complète la
seule organisation à se réjouir du
massacre le mouvement extrémiste
palestinien du djihad islamique qui par
la voix de son leader déclaré cet
après-midi en forme d'avertissement ce
qui est arrivé naturel les américains
doivent comprendre qu'en dépit de leur
puissance ils sont faibles et que ce
qu'il considère comme faibles
parviennent à vaincre la cia le fbi et
la force atomique américaine charles
enderlin est ce qu'israël explique ce
soir sa décision de fermer ses
frontières avec l'égypte avec la
jordanie
où il apparemment il n'y a pas
d'informations précises sur des menaces
dirigées contre israël venant de
l'extérieur en fait il s'agit d'une
précaution les isréliens parts de la de
l'hypothèse que les islamistes les mette
dans le même sac que les états unis donc
ici on effectivement également des
attentats important et plus localement
peut-être très rapidement de nouvelles
de nouveaux attentats suicides contre
les objectifs à l'intérieur d'israël est
ce que d'autres mesures de sécurité ont
été prises charles
les mesures de sécurité habituelles
évacuation d'ambassades et puis bouclage
en force et aux points de passage aux
points de contrôle entre israël et la
cisjordanie et la bande de gaza israël a
été victime du terrorisme bien sûr ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines
ces derniers mois est ce que vous avez
senti
disons une compassion particulière à
l'égard des américains aujourd'hui
oui vous connaissez les biens très
étroits qui unissent israël et les états
unis de nombreux israéliens sont
installés aux etats unis à new york à
washington et les lignes de téléphone
vers ces pays ce soir sont vraiment
embouteillé les israéliens se craignent
que de nombreux de leurs compagnes
nombre de leurs compatriotes soient
effectivement victimes de ces attentats
merci charles dans un instant il est 22h
une si vous nous rejoignez dans un
instant de nouvelles images des
décombres à new york les fouilles se
poursuivre elles dureront sans doute
longtemps peut-être que nous pouvons
découvrir déjà ces images elles sont
prêtes donc dans les décombres de ses
deux tours du world trade center les
recherches qui se poursuivent agnès
vahramian
comme s'il sortait de nulle part tels
des vagabonds je n'ai jamais vu ça de ma
vie dit celui-là en évacuant les abords
du world trade center
de loin une silhouette d'immeubles de la
dentelle c'est ce qu'il reste de la tour
de 110 étages la caméra filme comme un
automate s'approche au plus près de
l'acier du béton enchevêtrés des
plafonds des planchers en pin et comme
après un tremblement de terre devant cet
amant les pompiers quasiment hébété
préviennent d'abord lévis qui déboule ou
d'explosion en gaz
aucun bilan fiable pour l'instant sur le
nombre de victimes des milliers de
personnes étaient déjà au travail ce
matin
ce secouriste visiblement son chaque
peine à expliquer qu'il a bien vu
quelqu'un de vivant dans les ruines mais
que la personne est ensuite morte
au détour d'une rue la roue d'un avion
celui qui s'est crashé bien sûr posé là
comme un vestige de la catastrophe toute
la zone est fermée au public ni parce
que quelques habitants à la recherche de
leurs proches toute la nuit les
secouristes ont cherché des survivants
[Musique]
daniel oulié nous dire quelque chose sur
oussama ben laden oui juste avant une
dépêche qui vient d'arriver à l'instant
qui donne une toute petite idée du
nombre de victimes dont le maire de new
york monsieur julien me disais tout à
l'heure en début d'après midi qu'il
serait terrifiant pour l'heure un seul
hôpital l'hôpital saint-vincent de
new-york on a enregistré simplement pour
cet hôpital donc 209 victimes pour un
seul hôpital de la ville de new york 209
mains de sang froid oui ce que je
voulais dire c'est depuis ce soir tous
les spécialistes nous avons eu autour de
cette table ont désigné les américains
le font à leur tour comme auteurs
potentiels de cette série d'attentats
terrible de cet après midi savard ben
laden donc ce terroriste séoudiens
milliardaire réfugiés en afghanistan
tous les regards se tournent vers lui et
on a appris à l'occasion de ces
différentes interviews de spécialistes
qui sont venus autour de cette table
tout au long de cet après midi cette
soirée que cet homme finalement
on pouvait tout craindre de lui parce
qu'il avait je dirais à la manière d'
hitler dans mein kampf tout à fait écrit
dans un livre ce qu'il allait exactement
opéré dans les années à venir on n'avait
pas fixé le délai mais il est écrit noir
sur blanc dans les ouvrages qu'il a
publiés qu'il entendait bien grâce à son
argent grâce à son organisation et bien
tué tous les responsables américains
importants tuer n'importe quel américain
c'est son programme et il est en train
de l'appliquer on est en train de
découvrir ce qui est étonnant c'est que
est les américains qui ont été un moment
de sa vie politique sont alliés et bien
aujourd'hui se retrouve face à lui est
complètement désarçonné il semble bien
malgré tout même si les avis divergent
on a entendu des avis divergents que
c'est bien vers cet homme que tous les
regards se tournent ce soir c'est lui
qui a seul les moyens d'organiser une
telle logistique car on est tout de même
on reste éberlué ce soir souvenez vous
on entend du témoignage de deux pilotes
d'airbus de pilotes de gros porteurs qui
se disent qu'ils se demande même comment
on a pu faire pour organiser une telle
série d'attentats il ne voit pas comment
on pouvait diriger des avions de six
gros tonnage vers des objectifs
finalement aussi petit réduit fallen une
puissance une efficacité diabolique et
c'est ce qu'on a vu sur nos yeux
pourtant tout à l'heure on on vient pas
on n'a pas d'explication encore de
comment at on pu sur le sol américain
organisé une telle série d'attentats en
sip temps si bien organisé c'est
extraordinaire
les répercussions en france on va ré
entendre jacques chirac si vous n'avez
pas assisté en direct à son intervention
c'était tout à l'heure sur notre antenne
on reviendra aussi sur le plan
vigipirate et puis on écoutera les
réactions des passagers français qui ont
fait demi tour en l'air puisque tous les
vols vers les états unis sont suspendus
ce soir à d'abord voulu rajouter un mot
thierry klein effectivement oussama ben
laden en plus avait prévenu parce qu'on
sait qu'il a fait des menaces il ya
quelques semaines de cela disons qu'ils
voulaient viser à sa trame d'intérêts
importants américains notamment à
l'étranger mais il a déjà aussi frappé à
plusieurs reprises des ambassades
américaines on le sait en afrique noire
mais aussi sans doute à une base
militaire en arabie séoudite à dhahran
c'était il ya quelques années donc
oussama ben laden pour les services
américains c'est une vieille
connaissance il a effectivement
énormément d'argent ils financent à peu
près toutes les organisations radicales
islamistes de par le monde on trouve
même ça traces parmi les abou sayyaf par
exemple aux philippine sur l'île de jolo
donc c'est dire si vraiment il a les
moyens logistiques matériel d'organismes
d'organiser ce type d'opérations
militaires l'ondé de choc de ces
attentats aux états unis et s'est
propagé un peu partout dans le monde
occidental et notamment en france dans
un instant le détail du plan vigipirate
qui était réactivé ce soir d'abord on
écoute le président de la république
jacques chirac s'était donc en direct
sur notre antenne il y a
à trois quarts d'heure maintenant
mes chers compatriotes les attentats qui
ont frappé aujourd'hui
les états unis d'amérique
sont une épouvantable tragédie le jamais
aucun pays dans le monde a été la cible
d'attentats terroristes d'une telle
ampleur ni d'une telle violence
je veux redire au peuple américain la
solidarité de tous les français dans
cette dramatique épreuve
du conseil vote en particulier à toutes
les victimes à leur famille à leurs
proches
ce qui s'est produit aux etats-unis nous
concerne tous
j'imagine les sentiments que chacun
d'entre vous et prouve ce soir sentiment
d'horreur et peut-être d'inquiétude et
j'ai pensé qu'il était de mon devoir de
vous parler
nous ne connaissons à ce stade ni les
auteurs ni les raisons de ces actes
barbares
la situation requiert néanmoins sang
froid mais aussi vigilance et
mobilisation
c'est pourquoi j'ai réuni ce soir à
l'elysée un conseil restreint avec le
premier ministre et les ministres des
affaires étrangères de la défense de
l'intérieur des transports
les mesures de précautions qui
s'imposent ont été prises immédiatement
par le gouvernement et le plan
vigipirate que vous connaissez et mis en
oeuvre
nous agissons avec le premier ministre
bien sûr en étroite concertation et
évidemment tous les pouvoirs publics
sont mobilisés
par ailleurs je suis en contact avec les
responsables européens afin que nos
décisions soient bien coordonnées je
viens en particulier de m'entretenir
longuement avec le chancelier allemand
schoder et le premier ministre
britannique tony blair
la france c'est qu'on ne peut lutter
efficacement souvent contre le
terrorisme que par une action
déterminée et collectives et elle fera
ce qui doit être fait
voilà le détail la réactivation de
vigipirate dans un instant d'abord on
retrouve gérard leclerc à l'elysée
jacques chirac qui a abrégé son voyage
en bretagne gérard et qui avec cas
lionel jospin a réuni les ministres
concernés du gouvernement très vite dans
l'après midi absolument la situation est
suffisamment grave traumatisant pour que
les deux têtes de l'exécutif le
président le premier ministre affiche
une parfaite cohésion une totale
mobilisation les deux hommes ont
condamné dans les mêmes termes ces
attentats monstrueux abominable jacques
chirac vous l'avez dit abréger son
voyage en bretagne est rentré d'urgence
à paris lionel jospin a immédiatement
réuni les ministres concernés des
affaires étrangères de l'intérieur pour
pour examiner la situation pour prendre
les premières mesures notamment
déclenché le plan vigipirate renforcé
qui vise notamment à une plus grande
surveillance des aéroports des lieux
publics jacques chirac a donc réuni ce
conseil restreint avec les mêmes
ministres il s'est entretenu également
ils l'ont nous l'avons entendu avec les
chefs d'état européens notamment tony
blair et schröder et continuent pour
l'instant d'ailleurs ses entretiens avec
plusieurs chefs d'état de pays étrangers
et puis donc le présent république qui
s'est exprimée pour dire toute l'horreur
que lui inspirait ces événements pour
dire que tout ça nous concerner et donc
pour en appeler au sang froid à la
vigilance et à la mobilisation alors
vigipirate vous en parliez le détail de
ce plan plan renforcé a bien précisé
alain richard également le ministre de
la défense qui était notre invité ce
soir le détail donc yann fronty
les démineurs arrivent à toute vitesse
ici au coeur de paris un colis suspect a
été signalé la station de métro châtelet
et évacué et d'evry en bouche l'entrée
scène quasi identique un peu plus loin
dans la capitale rue des rosiers au
coeur du quartier juif de paris une
alerte à la bombe et c'est tout le
périmètre qui est bouclée fausse alerte
finalement les policiers repartent
bredouilles les policiers sur le pied de
guerre le plan vigipirate vient de
rentrer en vigueur une mesure
exceptionnelle prise après les attentats
perpétrés aux états unis et qui inquiète
les parisiens rencontrer aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant a dit simon
moi je reste est vraiment sous le choc
c enfin j'attends les représailles
maintenant pas ce qui va se passer c'est
voilà je me sens me fait vraiment
flipper
c'est tout bêtement à lui sinon c'est un
se produire c'est quelque chose qu'on
pouvait éventuellement redouté mais on
peut pas penser ça arriverait un jour
s'est fait peur pour votre propre
sécurité
directement non la somme
non directement dans sa m'effraie sur
les principes jour tu veux vraiment y
aller très très loin à la tour eiffel
les touristes américains eux sont
effrayés
je suis très choqué de cette femme c'est
une honte je me sens très triste que la
planète en arizona pour éviter que
pareil drame se produise en france le
plan vigipirate a donc de nouveau été
mise en place une première depuis la
guerre du golfe en 1991 policiers
militaires vont désormais renforcé les
contrôles dans les lieux publics aux
abords des ministères ou encore dans les
gares et les aéroports et puis on
l'apprend l'instant trois membres de l'
agence de promotion économique de la
région lyonnaise sont portées disparues
ce soir il était installé dans l'une des
deux tours du world trade center de new
york il s'agit de 2,2 américain et d'un
français l'inquiétude est évidemment
très vives toutefois c'est vrai que les
communications les liaisons sont très
difficile pour ne pas dire impossible
avec new york en ce moment donc un
espoir un espoir subsiste encore vous le
savez les vols à destination des états
unis ont été interrompus aujourd'hui
parfois des avions ont rebroussé chemin
en plein vol ça a été le cas pour d nice
new york où des neath los angeles
certains passagers ont appris en vol la
situation cette vague d'attentats sur la
côte est olivier théron était à
l'aéroport de nice aujourd'hui le vol
delta airlines dl 83 dû rebrousser
chemin il a quitté nice en début
d'après-midi et vers 17 heures alors
qu'il survolait les costes la nouvelle
est tombée l'espace américain est fermé
les 184 passagers en majorité des
américains sont donc revenus à nice à
leur arrivée ils ont appris la terrible
nouvelle
mozart c'est un désastre la vie a changé
tout est changé maintenant l'amérique
apprendre qu'elle est très vulnérable
une cellule d'assistance psychologique a
été mise en place pour prendre en charge
les passagers traumatisée par la
nouvelle ceux qui ont des amis ou de la
famille à manhattan
notre grosse difficulté c'est que les
liaisons vers les états unis les yeux
téléphoniques sont extrêmement encombré
et donc ces personnes souhaitent tout
d'abord téléphoné avec leurs familles et
ont beaucoup de mal à les joindre donc
on essaie de faire de notre mieux pour
libérer des lignes organiser l'accès aux
différents téléphones et puis être un
peu à la dans l'attende leurs souhaits
des pénos nous gérons pour eux bien sûr
la réservation de chambres d'hôtel ce
genre de choses les abords de l'aéroport
et le centre de carburant ont été mis
sous la protection de l'armée le plan
vigipirate renforcé est entrée en
vigueur à nice et puis il ya tout
simplement l'émotion la stupéfaction de
ceux qui dans notre pays ont découvert
en début d'après midi et nous étions en
direct dès 15h ces images ces images
incroyables de ces attentats à new york
et washington à marseille par exemple
réactions recueillies par michael dante
dans un café on découvre j'ai vu les
informations voilà
mais alors ces désastres quoi c'est
c'est impensable tiens toé la plus
grande puissance mondiale c'est voilà
alors est ce que ça a des conséquences
peut-être déjà ce cas une forme de
panique qui existent un peu partout par
rapport à ce qu'ils aillent au nez bah
oui réellement parce que on a appris
pendant la récréation on a appris qu'il
y avait eu ça à new york parce qu'il y
avait un café à côté qu'il avait
retransmis à la télé et c'est clair que
dans la classe on parlait que de ça est
bon c'est clair que on s'inquiète un peu
quoi mais on espère que la france ira
pas dedans
[Musique]
ni sous le choc c'est vrai mais c'est
complètement avec chaque match
qu'est ce qui vous concerne en fait je
dirais nous personnellement ici on n'est
pas touché directement mais je veux dire
c'est washington new york c'est quand
même le symbole de
un des symboles de l'occident dont
quelque part c'est un petit peu de
le montant qui est touché par ce drame
je pense qu'ils ont fait une longue
connerie parce que les américaines ont
répliqué savall est très très très mal
pour eux sur quoi vous sentez concerné
mais je me sens concerné parce que bosch
est pas c'est un monument du monde de
l'ovale ce trade center ça appartient au
monde là ils viennent de détruire
quelque chose
quelque chose qui appartient au monde
quoi c'est vraiment c'est une énorme
connerie qu'ils ont fait une énorme
et je rappelle la substance de ce que
déclarait alain richard sur notre
plateau où jacques chirac un peu plus
tard pas de menace particulière mais des
précautions daniel oui absolument on en
vient d'entendre un certain nombre de
témoignages je crois qu'il faut tout de
même essayer de raison garder on a
entendu le voyant la république jacques
chirac tout à leur dire qu'ils étaient
vraiment préoccupé au plus haut point
par cette situation qu'ils avaient des
relations directes avec ses collègues
européens et américains cela dit la
france n'est pas au premier rang des
cibles éventuelles de ces terroristes on
sait que bon l'amérique était touchée de
plein fouet et que ceux qui ont le plus
à craindre d'une certaine façon
d'actions terroristes à venir éventuel
ce serait l'allié le plus sûr de
l'amérique notamment par exemple dans le
conflit contre l'irak c'est à dire
l'angleterre dont l'armé est aux côtés
dans l'aviation est constamment côté de
l'amérique lorsqu'elle intervient encore
aujourd'hui régulièrement sur le
territoire irakien pour faire respecter
la loi fixé par les alliés occidentaux
et puis bien entendu israël qui a pris
toutes les précautions ce soit israël
allié inconditionnel des états unis la
france n'est donc pas forcément au
premier plan d'éventuelles cibles fixées
par des terroristes qui auraient encore
à agir dans les heures qui viennent
10h15 passé deux minutes 22h17
exactement si vous nous rejoignez bien
entendu édition spéciale consacrée à
cette déferlante terroriste à new york à
washington des scènes incroyables ont
fait un nouveau point nouveaux
commentaires sur ces images signées
daniel wolfromm
l'image est terrible presque irréel
ce en direct filmée par la télévision
américaine le boeing et ses dizaines de
passagers percute en une trajectoire
parfaite le haut de la tour du world
trade center vingt minutes plus tôt un
premier appareil s'était encastré dans
l'une des deux tours jumelles provoquant
déjà un terrible incendie
c'est la panique il est 9h ce matin et
des milliers d'employés sont déjà au
bureau
[Applaudissements]
certains appellent à l'aide d'autres
préfèrent se jeter par les fenêtres
les deux boeing détourné avec leurs
passagers ont été volontairement dirigé
par les pirates versés tours symboles de
la puissance financière américaine une
heure plus tard même scénario à
washington un troisième appareil
s'écrase sur le pentagone cette fois ci
le ministère de la défense le cerveau
militaire des etats unis
presque simultanément à new york une des
deux tours s'effondrent sur elle même
110 étages 300 mille tonnes d'acier de
béton
vingt minutes plus tard
explosion et destruction complète de sa
soeur jumelle
images d'apocalypse
le sud de manhattan
disparaît sous la poussière
[Applaudissements]
le maire de new york fait évacuer le sud
de la ville et parle d'un nombre
terrible de victimes sans avancer le
moindre bilan
voilà incendie très impressionnant à new
york incendie toujours à washington
apparemment thierry est là les pompiers
ne sont pas parvenus à maîtriser le feu
au pentagone effectivement plusieurs
heures après l'attaqué me dit-on
lincendie fait toujours rage dans une
aile du pentagone qui est vous le savez
le plus grand bâtiment du monde en fait
donc c'est un ensemble d'immeubles avec
beaucoup de bureaux administratifs dont
donc le bâtiment du ministère de la
défense et puis le dépêche que nous
recevons nous décrivent des scènes
d'horreur notamment à hoboken dans le
new jersey tout près donc new york un
hôpital à ciel ouvert a été installé des
dizaines de blessés sont couchés nolito
sur des civières d'autres se déplace
avec des béquilles on imagine évidemment
que les bilans vont fur et à mesure
s'alourdir dans la soirée mais des
dégâts énormes des bombardements
terrible c'est vrai daniel qui a cette
expression qui revient de nouveau pearl
harbor ou de pearl harbor terroristes
oui c'est de l'ancien secrétaire d'état
américain henry kissinger qui a lui-même
employé cette expression ce soir à
l'occasion d'une interview dans une
télévision américaine faut se remettre
en tête ce que pouvait être parle à
rebours pour les plus jeunes c'est
indécent 1941 l'an l'amérique hésitent à
entrer en guerre côté de l'angleterre
contre l'allemagne le japon la tac tac
sans déclaration de guerre les
américains sont surpris un peu de la
même façon qu'elles l'amérique et
surprise aujourd'hui par cette attaque
terroriste c'est le même genre d'
attaque les américains à l'époque avait
également prévenu de cette attaque
japonaise il n'avait pas voulu y croire
où il avait voulu laisser faire cette
attaque pour peut-être faciliter leur
entrée en guerre en tout cas aujourd'hui
visiblement ils ont été surpris voilà
l'analogie avec pearl harbor en décembre
ensuite la réplique des états unis fut
foudroyante entrée en guerre complète
contre le japon et l'allemagne voilà
l'analogie simplement un mot
supplémentaire sur le nombre des
victimes est tout à l'heure que on
parlait de bilan terrifiant la jolie que
dans les quatre avions qui sont donc
tombés aujourd'hui sur les deux
immeubles de manhattan washington est à
pittsburgh en californie il y avait 2
166 personnes ces 266 personnes sont
toutes mans ce soir et le pilote
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
françois grangier nous expliquer tout à
l'heure que de toute évidence les
pilotes de ses avions n'était plus aux
commandes lorsque les appareils ont été
précipités sur les twins towers ou sur
le pentagone
vraisemblablement les commandos
terroristes avaient pris les commandes
on leur à entendre à d'ailleurs dans un
instant direction new york 7h30
maintenant après ces attaques
terroristes et 6h30 après l'écroulement
de ses deux tours très spectaculaire
l'écroulement à new york donc et bien
les sauveteurs sont toujours évidemment
à pied d'oeuvre dans les décombres les
dernières images commentées par patrick
france
sortir au plus vite quitter cette zone
près des tours du world trade center
voilà l'urgence quelques minutes après
la double attaque à l'avion suicide
je suis en vie mon gars je suis en vie
17 hommes comme s'il revenait de l'enfer
ce sont les collègues les passants qui
porte les premiers secours
dont les rues voisines c'est la panique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chacun sa brique comité
et les policiers sont très vite débordé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais cette femme raconte qu'elle a
entendu un gros boum
et après il ya eu une grosse fumée tout
le monde a essayé de sortir et on a vu
arriver un autre avion de l'autre côté
il y avait de la fumée partout et des
gens qui ont tenté de sortir par les
fenêtres
après le crash du premier avion il y en
a eu un second ce ils venaient du sud et
a heurté la tour sud vers le haut de
l'immeuble ça ne peut être qu'une action
terroriste c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire
à washington près du pentagone un
hôpital improvisé à ciel ouvert sur les
pelouses où d'habitude on pique nique
entre collègues en cette fin d'été
les centres hospitaliers sont débordés
par l'afflux des blessés
on demande du sang en urgence
spontanément des dizaines d'américains
viennent faire en dons impossible pour
l'instant d'avoir envie lent il est
encore trop tôt la seule certitude il
sera le leur très vite
et dans un instant on ira en retournera
à manhattan où apparemment les habitants
continuent à quitter le sud de l'île
pour aller vers le nord nous sommes en
duplex si tout va bien avec alain de
chalvron à rome est ce que cela
fonctionne alain est-ce que vous
m'entendez
petit souci avec alain que nous
retrouverons dans un instant et bien on
va les découvrir ces images les toutes
dernières de manhattan image encore
apparemment d'exode commentaires agnès
gardé
[Applaudissements]
par milliers ils assistent incrédules à
cette scène hallucinante
les tours du world trade center qui
s'effondre une heure après avoir été
percutées par deux avions suicides
elles vont imploser l'une après l'autre
[Applaudissements]
homme/femme zenfants vente alors tenté
de fuir ce chaos indescriptible les
visages sont hagards sous le choc
les secours s'organisent dans une
précipitation effroyable c'est à la hâte
qu'on met les gens à l'abri pour
prodiguer les premiers soins
ainsi tout est exposé là où on se
trouvait
tout était noir il n'y avait plus de
lumière seules quelques personnes
n'avaient des briquets et puis il y
avait tellement de poussière partout
comment êtes vous senti de la mère
véronique et on a suivi quelqu'un avec
sa torche je vais voir
tout le même
c'est horrible avant lui et c'est la
deuxième fois pour moi j'étais déjà là
la première fois
bondée les autobus métro interrompu taxi
hors service c'est comme si la moitié de
la ville était devenue impraticable
alors par milliers les new yorkais
prennent la route à pied en direction du
nord de la ville pour fuir ce cauchemar
à l'image là encore très impressionnante
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à croire qu'on
est à new york surtout quand on quand on
connaît un peu la ville mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que c'est ces masses de gens
sur les routes ça évoque vraiment des
scènes d'exode daniel oui oui je voulais
simplement revenir sur quelle sera la
riposte éventuelle des états unis dans
les jours qui viennent je pense que les
américains sont un peuple qui a tendance
à l'isolationnisme on le sait mais qui
est également implanté dans le monde
entier qui est aujourd'hui le seul
gendarme du monde et je crois que dans
les jours les mois les années qui
viennent d'après les spécialistes que
nous avons pu interroger ce soir eh bien
ils vont trouver la réplique car ce type
d'événement va les obliger étant donné
le patriotisme qui conseille quiconque
ils considèrent qu'ils aient le fait
l'apanage des américains je crois que la
réplique attendra le temps qu'il faudra
mais je crois que décidément cette fois
ci les américains sont obligés de
répliquer de répliquer très très
fermement une capitale européenne que
nous n'avons pas encore visiter rome on
retrouve alain de chalvron avec les bd
on a vu qu'ils avaient des signes
d'inquiétude un peu partout ailleurs est
ce que c'est le cas aussi à rome italie
qui accueille des bases américaines il
faut le rappeler alain oui bien sûr
inquiétudes ici aussi à rome le
président du conseil italien était à
milan gens lui il est rentré en
catastrophe dans la capitale et l'est
réuni ses ministres et le le conseil des
ministres est en cours de réunion en
attendant le ministre de l'intérieur a
pris toutes les mesures de précaution
pour sauvegarder en particulier les
points sensibles comme les aéroports est
évidemment vous l'avez dit le point le
plus sensible du pays ce sont toutes ces
bases américaines qui s'échelonne du
nord jusqu'au sud jusqu'à la sicile
alors là les mesures ont été très strict
en particulier les travailleurs civils
de ses bases par exemple dans une base
près de libourne il y en avait huit
cents tous ces travailleurs civils ont
été évacués des bases
alain est ce que des mesures
particulières ont été prises il ya le
plan vigipirate en france est ce qu'il
ya des précautions policières qui sont
en cours à rome où ailleurs en italie
oui écouter bien sûr autour de
l'ambassade américaine
le quartier complètement bouclée dans
les aéroports la sécurité a été très
renforcée ou savait qu'elle était
souvent considéré comme un petit peu
laxiste ce n'est plus le cas les mesures
dans l'essayer dans les aéroports sont
maintenant très strictes et puis on voit
des patrouilles de police un petit peu
partout alors je voudrais vous dire
aussi que ici à rome il ya deux
capitales il ya l'italie et mais aussi
l'eau vatican et le pape a tenu à faire
savoir qu'il s'était tenu informé minute
par minute de ce qui se passait aux
états unis de ce qui se passait à new
york et à washington qu'il avait envoyé
un télégramme également à george bush
merci alain la place financière de milan
qui était en chute libre aujourd'hui
comme toutes les autres et dans quelques
minutes on fera le point justement sur
les répercussions financières et on sait
que ça va bien au delà de la finance
c'est le thermomètre que la confiance la
confiance de l'occident dans sa sécurité
le climat s'est détérioré d'un coup
aujourd'hui pour l'heure on va revenir
aux pistes du fbi à il est des pêches ou
le confirme de minute en minute c'est
bien oussama ben laden et son entourage
qui est montré du doigt ce soir on sait
que le régime des talibans lui s'est
défendue de toute complicité qui l'a
même condamné cet attentat oussama ben
laden ce ne serait pas la première fois
qu'il frapperait aux états unis on
revient sur l'historique des attentats
des incidents de terrorisme cas déjà
connus l'amérique avec olivier caroff
l'amérique avait mis longtemps à oublier
ces images c'était il ya près de huit
ans à l'entrée du world trade center un
peu après midi la fumée et la panique
l'ecri l'attentât une demi tonne
d'explosifs dans une camionnette bilan
six morts un millier de blessés
rapidement boucler lé enquête permettra
d'arrêter les quatre auteurs de cette
attaque à la bombe
des terroristes originaires du
moyen-orient ils seront condamnés chacun
à deux cent quarante années de prison
arrêté et condamné à son tour leur chef
omar abdelrahman il dirigeait une
organisation intégriste égyptienne sa
folle ambition détruire des lieux
symboliques de new york comme le siège
des nations unies vidéo à l'appui le fbi
y avait au moins pu déjouer le complot
de ses apprentis terroristes islamistes
mais la sphère n'a pas tardé à inspirer
d'autres criminels
19 avril 95 oklahoma city un camion
piégé et ventre cet immeuble des
services fédéraux l'administration
américaine jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était
l'attentât le plus meurtrier de
l'histoire du pays 168 victimes
cette fois c'est un ancien jihai décorés
pendant la guerre du golfe qui a commis
l'attentât timothy mcveigh a été exécuté
en juin dernier les états unis s'en
rende compte leur territoire est à la
merci de n'importe quelle folie
meurtrière tragique confirmation un an
plus tard une bombe déposée dans la
foule en plein jeux olympiques d'atlanta
tue une personne en blesse six autres
les mesures de sécurité étaient pourtant
draconiennes il faudra deux ans pour
trouver le coupable l'un des dix
criminels les plus recherchés à l'époque
depuis toute la politique américaine de
lutte antiterroriste était en crise un
cible de toutes les critiques le fbi est
arrogant pour beaucoup incompétent pour
quelques-uns en juillet dernier george
bush lui a donné un nouveau directeur
robert muller devait rendre confiance
aux américains tâche difficile dans un
pays n'importe qui peut posséder une
arme mais où personne n'a de cartes
d'identité alors un témoignage tout de
suite à propos d'oussama ben laden celui
de l'un de ses proches le mollah
samiullah qu qui réside au pakistan donc
est à frontière de l'afghanistan
tout près de la ville de peshawar qui
considéré comme l'une des capitales de
l'islamisme ou beaucoup d'ebola talibans
d'afghanistan ont été formés c'est
bernard lebrun qui a pu joindre le
mollah samiullah qu à par téléphone
écoutez sa réaction après ces attentats
et les accusations concernant oussama
ben laden
cet homme est un mot là il est même l'un
des chefs des mollahs pas cette année il
s'appelle sami ou lac et dirige au
pakistan à la frontière afghane ce qu'on
appelle une madrassa une école coranique
qui forment les jeunes étudiants
islamistes les talibans à plusieurs
reprises le mollah samiullah qu a
rencontré le saoudien oussama bin laden
en exil dans les montagnes afghanes nous
l'avons joint tout à l'heure voici son
analyse évidemment très mesuré quant aux
accusations portées contre eux pinède
il faut d'abord que les américains
enquêtent et vérifie qui sont les vrais
acteurs de cet acte
faire porter la responsabilité à une
seule personne est incroyable on ne peut
pas prétendre que c'est lui le cruel
occulter les vrais acteurs
comment peut-on croire personnes exilées
dans les montagnes de manipuler le monde
du terrorisme espoir c'est impossible
l'amérique a forcé le monde à croire que
les musulmans sont ses plus grands
ennemis
ceci n'est pas vrai les musulmans ne
sont pas les ennemis des américains
à kaboul dès cet après midi le
gouvernement islamiste n'a pas fermement
condamné les attentats sur le sol
américain mais annie est très fortement
avoir un quelconque rapport avec
concernant pin laden l'un des ministres
a réfuté qu'il ait pu organiser de son
camp dans les montagnes une action
terroriste d'une telle ampleur
alors thierry thulliez bien entendu la
version d'un proche d'oussama ben laden
mais ils restent plus que jamais se
confirme d'instant en instant
le suspect numéro un il s'agit toujours
d'une hypothèse mais c'est vrai que
oussama ben laden finalement n'est pas
tout à fait un inconnu on le connaît sa
famille très riche est originaire
d'arabie saoudite et du yémen
ils ont été très proches pendant de très
longues années de la famille royale
saoudienne actuellement au pouvoir qui
sont qui est actuellement le meilleur
allié des états unis c'est un peu le
paradoxe de cette histoire est
d'ailleurs oussama ben laden pendant de
nombreuses années a été soutenue même
parfois parrainé par la cia notamment en
afghanistan lorsque l'armée rouge
étaient déployées en afghanistan alors
le divorce est intervenue à la fin des
années 80 divorce avec les états unis
mais ils divorcent aussi avec la famille
royale saoudienne il a commencé alors
une longue errance qui l'a conduit
notamment au soudan et puis finalement
en afghanistan il est toujours réfugié
et de là en fait ils financent un
certain nombre de groupes radicaux je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure aux philippines
mais aussi en tchétchénie évidemment
encore au soudan qui est toujours
considéré comme un pays terroriste bref
oussama ben laden a une carte d'identité
très longue très chargé et c'est vrai
que les états unis depuis de très
nombreuses années cherche finalement à
le neutraliser c'est à dire en gros à
l'éliminer daniel oui je devrai
simplement revenir sur l'étonnement qui
peut être le vôtre qui est le nôtre de
voir qu'un pays comme les etats-unis un
véritable continent très loin de
l'europe puisse ainsi être
attaqués de cette façon là mais je crois
que c'est un peu ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs en ce moment en israël
lorsque des kamikazes mettent leur vie
au bout de leurs idées bien je crois que
toutes les mesures de sécurité possibles
et imaginables ne serviront jamais rien
et on vient de s'en apercevoir cet
après-midi alors les états unis frapper
l'occident fragilisé on le disait
témoins
les bourses ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui sur les places financières
on va en parler avec vous jean paul
chapelle d'abord tout simplement les
chiffres la chute la chute libre des
places boursières aujourd'hui cyrille
devaud
journée de deuil pour la finance
mondiale toutes les bourses américaines
sont restées fermées aujourd'hui car les
actions terroristes viennent de frapper
la capitale économique de la planète les
tours jumelles du world trade center
dominés wall street le gigantesque
quartier d'affaires c'est donc le
symbole de la puissance financière
internationale qui vient de s'effondrer
entraînant toutes les bourses du monde
dans la tourmente
en france le cac 40 perd 7,4 pour cent
et atteint son plus bas niveau depuis
mars 99 en europe londres chute de 5 7%
à la clôture milan de cette garrigue lui
% francfort de 8,3 pour cent
amsterdam 2 7% ce soir les spécialistes
sont très inquiets
le moral des consommateurs et la
consommation jusqu'à présent tonné la
croissance avec cet événement dramatique
à mon avis le moral des consommateurs
aux états unis et dans le reste du monde
va être attaqué et donc je pense que les
bourses vont chuter cet après midi
pendant que la place de londres et
évacuées par mesure de sécurité afin
d'éviter un krach la plupart des
cotations mondiales sont stoppés à
toronto mexico lisbonne ou sao paulo
parallèlement le marché du dollar est
suspendu pour enrayer sa chute notamment
face à l'euro la monnaie européenne se
négocie en soirée à +20 dollars 91 son
plus haut depuis fin août comme toujours
lors des catastrophes les professionnels
spécule sur les valeurs refuge l'or
gagne plus de 10% en quelques heures et
le baril de pétrole flambe à près de 30
dollars 12 pour cent de plus que ce
matin et puis le dollar était en chute
aussi en chute assez importante face à
l'euro demain toutes les places
financières américaines seront fermées
ça ressemble à un krach
jean-paul chapelle c'est un crack en
europe toutes les places boursières ont
chuté d'au moins 7% en une journée c'est
un crack c'est évidemment l'effet domino
qui commence à s'installer sur les
places financières
c'est clair que tout le monde a envie de
vendre et personne n'a envie d'acheter
parce que c'est sans précédent ce qu'il
vient de se passer d'un point de vue
technique la bourse de new york n'a pas
été touché c'est à dire que les
transactions pour s était tout près mais
absolument à wall street mais elle n'a
pas été touchée mais évidemment la
communauté financière comme la
communauté américaine dans son ensemble
est totalement en état de choc c'est une
situation de crise financière vous
l'avez dit wall street ne rouvrira pas
demain et les autorités financières et
boursières décideront demain de la date
de la reprise de la bourse que ce soit
le wall street
le new york stock exchange où même le
nasdaq qui ne coûteront pas demain on
l'a vu les places européennes ont
littéralement craqué le pétrole flambe
évidemment dollar s'effondre l'euro
cyniquement reprendre de la valeur à +20
dollars 91 mais c'est clair que les
conséquences au delà de la bourse seront
sans précédent parce que vous savez
qu'un ralentissement économique aux
états unis essentiellement du fait de la
consommation et que dans un état de
de méfiance comme il peut y en avoir
actuellement et ben la confiance et la
consommation ne peuvent que chuté et les
risques de récession qu'on prédisait
dans un avenir proche sans vous
accélérez mais justement expliqué nous
ça on sent bien quand on regarde ces
images on se sent tous un peu concernés
on sent qu'il y à une fêlure
comment ça se traduit en fait
économiquement comment expliquer qu
ensuite les bourses suivent et que sa
chute ce qui est clair c'est que les
marchés financiers ont besoin d'un
horizon plutôt dégagé or là la situation
internationale et plus que troublée on
est chaotique sais pas quelles seront
les conséquences il est clair que les
les gens qui ont des valeurs
dans le doute préfèrent vendre et il n'y
a pas en face d'eux d'opérateur pour
acheter pour miser sur un optimisme
quelconque est donc la conséquence
directe qu'il ya plus de vendeurs que
d'acheteurs et donc les cours
s'effondrent kofi annan on attendait la
réaction du secrétaire général de l'onu
la voix si on écoute on restera express
j'aimerais exprimer mes profondes
condoléances aux victimes et au
gouvernement des états unis united
states
il ya aucun doute que ces attaques sont
des actes délibérés de terrorisme
parfaitement prévu coordonnées
je les condamne complètement apte mais
le terrorisme de reto battu réseau lan
partout il apparaît dans de tels moments
le calme et le jugement sont plus
importants que jamais hamon est ce un
show d'annaba la situation continue
d'évoluer à new york on apprend c'est
cnn qu'il affirme qu'un immeuble proche
du world trade center pourrait
s'effondrer semble-t-il en raison de
dommages qu'il aurait subis suite à la
chute des deux twins towers on attend
des précisions là dessus à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de là on rejoint
on vous retrouve etienne leenhardt à
washington vous décriviez il ya une
heure une ville une ville morte une
ville paralysée où la vie avait disparu
qu'en est il ce soir maintenant à
l'heure qu'il est
poursuis ta vie de tous les américains
tous les washingtoniens les habitants de
la région de washington sont rentrés
chez eux pour évidemment sur les
télévisions qui relaie minute par minute
seconde par seconde l'évolution de la
situation pour suivre tout cela en
direct nous venons d'apprendre que le
président george bush qui je vous disais
tout à l'heure était dans le nebraska où
il a tenu un conseil avec les principaux
responsables de la sécurité à l'autre
bout du pays donc le président george
bush vient de cliquer le nebraska à bord
d'air force one pour revenir vers
washington dc où on l'attend donc dans
le sens le mans 3 ou 4 heures et où il
devrait faire une une deuxième
déclaration vous vous souvenez qu'on me
rende la première déclaration il a dit
que ces actes d'une part dans ces actes
terroristes ne pouvait rester impunie et
ne resterait pas impuni il ya toute une
partie de l'opinion publique américaine
maintenant qu'ils demandent vengeance et
tout un tas de questions qui commencent
à se poser notamment des questions et je
crois que j'en avais parlé tout à
l'heure sur l'efficacité des services de
renseignement américains comment comment
est il possible que l'on puisse comme
cela au coeur des détournements en plein
ciel au dessus de new york comment
peut-on visé l'immeuble qui est sans
doute il meuble le mieux protégé des
états unis à savoir le pentagone le
ministère de la défense alors vengeance
est ce qu on a une idée déjà de ce que
cela pourrait signifier etienne ou
est-ce qu'il est encore trop tôt pour en
parler
beaucoup trop tôt pour en parler mais en
même temps le président george bush a
été extrêmement clair dans sa première
déclaration dont il faut s'attendre
d'une manière ou d'une autre d'abord
parce que militairement il ne peut pas
comme cela donnait l'impression que il
espérait ensuite parce que son opinion
publique il est clair que l'opinion
publique américaine va réclamer
vengeance dans les heures qui viennent à
travers les journaux à travers les
chaînes de télévision on a entendu à
longueur d'antenne sur certaines chaînes
d'information d'aidé militaire en
retraite dire que cet acte ne pouvait
pas rester impuni que le sanctuaire
encore une fois avait été violée et que
donc il fallait frapper il frappé fort
le problème c'est évidemment frapper où
et je pense que le principal test de la
présidence de george bush comment le
président américain qui vous le savez en
temps mais son mandat il y à peine à
peine quelques mois comment le président
américain va-t-il gérer cet épouvantable
tragédie nationale des scénarios qui
sont échafaudés déjà etienne n'ont aucun
scénario sur l'alaric toi je voulais
dire bien évidemment aucun scénario dit
il est bien trop tôt les sont résidents
américains rentrer à washington colline
powell lui même le ministre des affaires
étrangères vous savez n'était pas en
territoire américain il était en
amérique du sud au pérou et devait se
rendre en colombie pour une visite
extrêmement importante donc bien
évidemment
l'administration américaine dans son
ensemble et les points sont complètement
éparpillés mais dans les heures qui
viennent il est évident que on connaît
l'efficacité des américains ont connu de
leur pragmatisme aussi il est évident
qu'il ya des réponses qui sont attendus
par le peuple américain et qui ne
manqueront pas de venir quelle qu'elle
soit merci etienne hameau thierry avant
d'aller à new york entendre de nouvelles
réactions que nous avons tourné oui
juste pour dire que la grande difficulté
pour changer vous ça va devoir en fait
de cibler effectivement les groupes qui
va falloir sans doute bombardé d'une
certaine manière on a vu déjà lorsque
les américains ont décidé d'essayer de
d'éliminer en fait oussama ben laden en
afghanistan
ça avait échoué les américains m'envoyer
une toute une série de tomahawk à
travers le golfe persique savait pas
c'est est passée carrément au dessus de
l'irak que pour atteindre l'afghanistan
puis finalement ça n'avait pas abouti la
même chose quelques années après
d'ailleurs au soudan bref il ne s'agit
pas de faire la guerre à un état mais à
des groupes terroristes mobile qui se
cache et c'est là finalement toute la
difficulté effectivement pour pour les
américains en janvier on en est ce que
les états unis mais comme les autres
pays occidentaux ne sont pas
complètement démuni face à ce genre de
situation ainsi précisément et c'est
bien pourquoi d'ailleurs et c'est un peu
l'ironie aussi de l'histoire george bush
et le premier lorsqu'il est arrivé à la
maison blanche de paris
qui a parlé effectivement de menaces
terroristes et il le souhaitait mettre
au point un système de bouclier
antimissile pour faire face à ces
menaces n'ont pas d'états voyous ou
d'état important qu'ils pouvaient
frapper les états unis mais ces groupes
terroristes qui effectivement pouvait un
jour frapper le territoire américain et
bien il a eu raison
[Musique]